welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford School of Medicine
today my guest is Dr Robin Carhart
Harris Dr Carhart Harris is a
distinguished professor of Neurology and
Psychiatry at the University of
California San Francisco
he is one of the leading researchers in
the field of psychedelics and how they
change neural circuitry in the brain his
laboratory is responsible for
understanding for instance how
psilocybin also sometimes referred to as
magic mushrooms change neural circuitry
in the brain such that new ideas and new
forms of learning occur his laboratory
is also responsible for carrying out
various clinical trials some of which
have demonstrated that appropriate
dosages of psilocybin can alleviate
major depression in more than 67 percent
of people that take the drug now this is
not to say that everybody should take
psilocybin in today's discussion
describes both the clinical trials and
why treatments with psychedelics in some
cases work and in some cases do not work
in order to treat major depression as
well as discussions around psilocybin
lysergic acid diethylamide sometimes
also referred to as LSD as well as DMT
and how these change the brain and how
those brain changes can relate to
changes in mental health as it relates
to depression and other psychiatric
challenges as well as how psychedelics
are being applied in order to change a
neural circuitry for sake of expanding
different aspects of the human mind
including creativity intelligence and
much more during today's discussion Dr
Carhart Harris teaches us about the
history of the study of psychedelics as
well as how the legislature that is the
laws surrounding psychedelics are
evolving in the United States and
Elsewhere for the use of psychedelics to
treat psychiatric challenges by the end
of today's discussion you'll have a
thorough understanding of how
psychedelics work both in the short term
during the actual Journey or trip in
fact much of my discussion today with Dr
Carhart Harris talks about the different
aspects of the Psychedelic journey and
how those relate to therapeutic outcomes
and of course by the end of today's
discussion you will also understand the
long-term effects of psychedelics that
is how they can actually rewire the
Brain before we begin I'd like to
emphasize that this podcast is separate
from my teaching and research roles at
Stanford it is however part of my desire
and effort to bring zero cost to
Consumer information about science and
science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is eight sleep
eight sleep makes Smart mattress covers
with cooling Heating and sleep tracking
capacity I've talked many times before
on this podcast about the fact that
sleep is the foundation of mental health
physical health and performance one
absolute critical variable to getting
excellent sleep is the temperature of
your sleeping environment that is in
order to fall and stay deeply asleep at
night your body temperature needs to
actually drop by about one to three
degrees and in order to wake up in the
morning feeling refreshed and alert your
body temperature has to increase by
about one to three degrees there are a
lot of ways to control the temperature
of your sleeping environment but one of
the best ways is to control the
temperature of your actual mattress the
surface that you're sleeping on with
eight sleep you can do this very easily
there's a simple to use app where you
can program in the temperature of your
mattress across the night so you can
make it slightly cool the beginning of
the night getting cooler putting you
into deep sleep and then rapid eye
movement sleep and all of that in terms
of its impact on your sleep can be
tracked within the same app I've been
sleeping on an eight sleep mattress
cover for more than two years now and it
has completely transformed my sleep if
you'd like to try Aid sleep you can go
to eightsleep.com huberman for their
exclusive Memorial Day savings now
through June 5th 2023. eight sleep
currently ships in the USA Canada United
Kingdom select countries in the EU and
Australia again that's eightsleep.com
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by levels levels is a program that
lets you see how different foods affect
your health by giving you real-time
feedback on your diet using continuous
glucose monitor
one of the most important factors in
terms of your energy levels and your
immediate and long-term Health are your
blood glucose or blood sugar levels as
they're commonly called with levels you
can assess how different foods and
activities impact your blood glucose
levels when I did this it taught me
several things first of all it taught me
that certain foods really Spike my blood
glucose levels and while spikes in blood
glucose aren't always a bad thing I was
able to assess how certain foods were
spiking my blood glucose too much such
that I would have post-eating dips in
energy levels and by removing those
foods and substituting in other Foods it
really evened out my energy levels so if
you're interested in learning more about
levels and trying a continuous glucose
monitor yourself go to levels.link
huberman right now levels is offering an
additional two free months of membership
again that's levels.link huberman
today's episode is also brought To Us by
hvmn Ketone IQ Ketone IQ is a ketone
supplement that increases blood ketones
now most people have heard of the
so-called ketogenic diet but most people
including myself are not on the
ketogenic diet that is I and most people
eat complex carbohydrates fruits and
things of that sort in addition to
Quality proteins Etc it turns out that
even if you're not following a ketogenic
diet increasing your blood ketones can
still have benefits so for instance I
use Ketone IQ anytime I want to do
extended bouts of focused work preparing
for podcasts research writing grants and
if I ever want to exercise but I don't
have time to eat or I don't want to have
my gut full of food taking Ketone IQ and
thereby increasing in my blood ketones
allows me to do cognitive work or
physical workouts without getting hungry
and with plenty of energy and cognitive
Focus if you'd like to try Ketone IQ you
can go to hvmn.com huberman to save 20
off again that's hvmn.com huberman I'm
pleased to announce that I will be
hosting two live events in September of
2023. the first live event will take
place in Toronto on September 12th the
second live event will take place in
Chicago on September 28th both Live
Events will include a lecture and a
question and answer period and are
entitled The Brain body contract during
which I will discuss tools and science
related to mental health physical health
and performance I should mention that a
lot of that content will have absolutely
no overlap with content covered
previously on the huberman Lab podcast
or elsewhere if you're interested in
attending either or both of these events
please go to hubermanlab.com tour and
enter the code huberman to get early
access to tickets once again that's
hubermanlab.com tour and use the code
huberman to access tickets I hope to see
you there and now for my discussion with
Dr Robin Carhart Harris Dr Carhart
Harris welcome
I've been wanting to talk to you for a
long time I certainly have known who you
are for quite a while because I place
you in this very small but very special
and important category of researchers
who has been pioneering the use of
psychedelics for the treatment of
specific clinical conditions and really
carrying the torch for essentially the
entire field so I want to start with a
voice of gratitude and say thank you for
doing this incredibly important work
could you tell us a little bit about
what psychedelics are in fact I'm
curious as to how the name psychedelic
ever came to be and what you think they
potentially reveal about the workings of
the brain and then we'll talk about the
clinical applications sure well
or even that one is is a kind of hot one
because opinions differ on how to define
psychedelic
well perhaps a good starting place is to
start with the etymology where did the
word come from and it was a Brit
excommunicated living in in Canada
Humphrey Osmond
who was due to present a paper at a
National Academy of Sciences meeting on
psychotomimetics drugs that mimic
aspects of psychosis in their action and
certain drugs like mescaline let's see
1956 and LSD
were on on the bill and he felt
dissatisfied with them being under this
category of psychotomimetics and felt
that the signature psychological effects
of these compounds went beyond just
mimicking psychotic symptoms and so he
wanted to find a more apt term to speak
to in a sense the principal component of
their action and he jotted down a few
different possibilities about a dozen or
so I think and one of them was
psychedelic actually has started as an
ended up being psychedelic and he had a
correspondence going on with another
Brit also living in the US all this
Huxley
where they were playing with some
terms to refer to these compounds and
and uh in the end uh Osmond won with
psychedelic and he had this little ditty
of um
to Fathom hell or saw Angelic just take
a pinch of psychedelic
um that's where you put the disclaimer
um and so
um what does that mean it's two ancient
Greek words psyche means the human mind
or if we're being uh actually true to
the ancient Greek it means Soul
um and then the other component
means to make clear or to make visible
or to make manifest or to reveal so all
of those work
um and it's it's a neologism it's a
made-up word but it does have that
ancient Greek origin and it's speaking
to this principle that these compounds
reveal aspects of the psyche
of the human mind the soul that are
ordinarily not
entirely visible
um and so that's the etymology and it's
wonderfully poetic but I happen to think
it's also very accurate it's a useful
term because it's sort of you might say
valence non-specific it doesn't say
you're gonna have a great time or that
you're gonna go mad uh it's more that it
reveals a psyche and it could be hellish
but it could be Heavenly
um and uh so that's the etymology and
also a bit of the psychology
um and sort of you know pointing to the
phenomenology the subjective experience
but there's also a pharmacology here and
quite recently there was put out a
consensus statement about psychedelics
that's really referring to what we call
the classic psychedelics to say that
these are all compounds that work on a
particular receptor in the brain the
serotonin 2A receptor
and that's another way that we could
Define these compounds I said this one's
a little hot because I'm of the view
that while the pharmacology is really
useful how the drugs work chemically you
can't avoid the phenomenology and if
we're true to the etymology where the
term came from then we must recognize
and we cannot neglect the subject of
experience
thank you for that beautiful description
of what brought us to today in terms of
using the word psychedelics and now it's
thrown around all the time yeah too much
yeah too much and and I'm guessing um
well not guessing I'm certain that it's
uh also used to describe many compounds
that don't touch the 5h2 5ht2a the
serotonin 2A receptor so
um there is a broader categorization by
most people and um it'll be interesting
to see where all the nomenclature naming
goes for the time being I'd love for you
to tell us a bit more about this idea
that psychedelics uh however one defines
them can reveal something about the mind
that can't be revealed otherwise are you
talking about the subconscious I mean
you know psychologists and most famously
Freud but also young and all also
neuroscientists I think
um think about subconscious processing I
think perhaps the most Salient example
for me that's outside the realm of of um
anything psychedelic would be blind
sight this phenomenon that you take
people that are blind but still have
some connectivity in their brain and you
present them you know a board with or
computer screen with different number of
dots on each side and you say how many
dots are on each side of the screen and
they say what do you mean I can't see
the screen I'm blind you say well just
guess and their guess rate is accurate
far more than chance would would predict
so they have so-called blind sight and
people have said well this is the
subconscious revealing itself
um there's no psychedelic drug involved
but what you're describing is a
pharmacologic induced state that reveals
something that normally should we assume
is masked or that we are oblivious to uh
even though it's expressing itself what
what does it mean for these drugs to be
re you know revealing something about
the workings of the mind that would not
be obvious to us otherwise yeah so so
the example of blind sight is
interesting but it's different blind
sight would be referring to
non-conscious processing maybe implicit
processing say stuff going on in the
mind in perception in a sense that is
below the threshold of conscious
awareness but yet it's influencing you
so it's sort of it's kind of related but
it's different so in in-depth psychology
psychoanalysis psychodynamic psychology
you know
Sigmund Freud Carl Jung and so on we
talk about the unconscious
and there it's more about the kind of
Blood and Guts of The Human Condition
the human nature both the personal
unconscious so things that you might not
want to necessarily be conscious of
because it's painful so that that's the
repression aspect pushing it out of
conscious awareness repressed memories
in particular yeah like traumatic
memories
um difficult
relationships it could be complex trauma
not necessarily just a specific you know
index trauma but a series of traumas
um and then you have the collective
unconscious which was really Carl Jung's
contribution to say that
um
you know there's a transpersonal quality
to the unconscious there's aspects about
humans not just this individual human
as aspects to our mouth our minds our
psyches that are not fully available to
conscious awareness but can come up in
certain States you know psychoanalysis
went crazy for dreaming as as their
Royal Road to a knowledge of the
unconscious that was Freud
um
but uh we now know with psychedelics and
this was what drew me into the area was
discovering literature
um that was speaking to this particular
action the Psychedelic action and we're
saying that when these drugs like LSD
psilocybin found in magic mushrooms
um
when they're used in in Psychotherapy
material comes up that maybe may have
been repressed
that that is of you know therapeutic
value and awareness and insight of this
material seems to catalyze the
therapeutic process with you know strong
emotional release these cathartic
experiences and uh and insights you know
whether they're insights that are
personal
or whether they're transpersonal
but for me this is really where the meat
of it is with psychedelics and classic
psychedelics in particular the likes of
compounds like LSD and psalocybin I
would say that if it wasn't for this
action by classic psychedelics we
wouldn't be so interested in
psychedelics I I think we only had
compounds like ketamine and MBA May
cannabis
there just it could be said broadly
speaking to be psychedelic like I don't
think it necessarily would have captured
the world's attention as psychedelics
are right now I actually think it's a
major Gap to fill is this principal
action of the classic psychedelics what
does what does this mean that I'm
referring to psyche revealing what is
that and I suppose where I'm going with
this is what is that in terms of the
biology as well what's going on in the
brain and the body when people become
aware of things that previously they
weren't fully aware of
I'd like to talk about some of the
clinical trials that you've been
involved with in particular looking at
psilocybin as you mentioned the
principal
hallucinatory psychedelic agent in magic
mushrooms
I'd like to start with a kind of nuts
and bolts question just so that
everyone's on the same page
I've read the papers that you've
published and that others have published
in this area and typically the dosages
used in these trials are
25 milligrams of psilocybin and we talk
about one recent trial in particular
that compared 25 to 10 milligrams to
more frequent use of very small amounts
one milligram over three weeks for
instance
however
when people talk about magic mushrooms
they often talk about gram doses of the
mushroom because I'm assuming that they
contain milligram dosages of psilocybin
here we're not encouraging use of any
kind these are clinical trials but for
um Clarity of understanding
what is the conversion typically like
one gram of magic mushrooms will contain
how many milligrams of psilocybin on
average because what I what I'm trying
to do here is is calibrate people to
this idea of microdosing versus macro
dosing and that's fairly straightforward
to do with respect to the clinical
trials but then in the a lot of the lay
discussion around this you hear about
heroic doses versus micro Doses and so I
think there's a lot of confusion so if
you would
um educate us on this idea of what's a
micro dose and perhaps also how many
milligrams of psilocybin are contained
in a gram of quote unquote magic
mushrooms sure well a micro dose is uh
neither of these are that simple but uh
they're fun it's a fun challenge but
Micro dose one definition is that it's a
dose of typically a classic psychedelic
like LSD or psalocybin
um that is uh that has sub-perceptible
psychedelic effects like it doesn't put
you into a noticeable altered state of
consciousness that feels like you're
tripping
um
and if that was LSD it looks as though
the threshold is around about
let's see 10 11 12 micrograms micrograms
microgram very clear here yeah Kroger
yeah so 10 so 10 micrograms of LSD are
you saying will not induce visual
hallucinations in most people so it's
it's that's threshold level that's about
the level that that some people who are
sensitive could feel it
um but if you were to talk to the
microdosing gurus they might say that
that's kind of the ballpark for an LSD
dose that you would consider a micro
dose and then you would take sort of
semi-regularly it's typically something
like one day on one day off or one day
on two days off this kind of thing
there's different protocols and um
yeah so you know some like Jim faderman
um uh one of the popularizers of micro
dosing I think would say that a true
microdose should be sub-perceptible you
shouldn't feel it yet the assumption is
it's going to change you in some way on
a kind of trait level more than a state
level
and maybe behaviorally and the typical
Story Goes it will improve well-being
and maybe maybe it could improve certain
aspects of cognition say related to
creative thinking
um I emphasize them maybe there because
that's another angle with micro dosing
we're kind of waiting for some
compelling evidence as things stand
right now I'd say we lack that
compelling evidence there's some
suggestive stuff but often the study
designs aren't that strong it's really
hard to do a study with microdising
because you need to have permission to
give people a micro dose that you know
for practical reasons they would go home
with and
um otherwise you you're requiring them
to be in the lab say three times a week
for X number of weeks to meet the
criteria of a course of micro dosing
which might be you know two or three
times a week for say a month and that's
a hard thing to do in a lab study it's
expensive
you need to do that against a suitable
control so a placebo control and there
is a study that's been done in New
Zealand that has some interesting
preliminary data that did I think kind
of did the design right
um
but uh it hasn't been published yet
um I've seen some positive findings
presented around improvements in in mood
but it's a bit early to get too excited
about that
um needs to go through peer review and
all that
um
but as things stand you know the
evidence is pretty thin and and you know
we have to be honest about that we did
Quite A Creative Study uh with my
colleagues at Imperial the guy leading
that balash shaghetti Hungarian Chap and
did a really Creative Design very much
his brainchild he instructed people to
do their own blinding their own
placebo-controlled blinding of their own
micro dosing so this was a classic
citizen science study like
do-it-yourself science where they would
get their LSD tabs and chop them up put
them into gel capsules opaque and have
other capsules that are the placebos
that they just close empty capsule and
then there was a whole barcode scan
technique so that you you kind of
shuffle them up you know but they've got
the barcode in the QR code so you can
break the code later on but once you've
shuffled them up you no longer know
which ones had have the the micro dose
in and which ones are empty was this LSD
this was LSD also tried it with
mushrooms but the issues with the
mushrooms was people would burp
sometimes it Belch and then they'd have
this mushroom taste so then he
instructed people to get some like
non-psychoactive mushroom material to
put in so it's really not an easy study
not an easy study and and uh it was I
love that kind of science you know real
creative first mover kind of Science and
the results are fascinating because
um the short story is that the micro
dosing didn't
um compellingly beat the placebo it did
not it didn't and he controlled because
he asked he controlled for expectancy so
people was positive expectancy which is
in a sense the vehicle that carries the
placebo response it's why you have a
placebo is the positive can drive a
therapeutic effect to you know a large
extent
so he measured that pre-trial and then
used it to kind of correct for the
response and how did it work those who
got a placebo
but thought they got a micro dose did as
well as those who thought they got a
microdase and did get a micro dose so it
was the bigger effect the the majority
of the effect was in thinking that you
got a micro dose so in a sense it was a
victory for the power of the placebo
response and it's created all sorts of
controversy people don't want to believe
it you know that kind of thing but
that's the beauty of science isn't it
that science is not about what you want
to believe that right there is the
beauty of science really
I love that experiment of kudos to them
I'm not going to attempt to say his last
name correctly tried yeah no no I think
you you got it um
you were involved in a clinical trial
that was published last year comparing
25 milligrams of
psilocybin to 10 milligrams of
psilocybin it's a very um to uh a drug
called
escitalopram yeah yeah Lexapro Lexapro
um and this one milligram over three
week
um dosage uh in I'm wanting to discuss
the results of that study a bit
um and some of the other trials that
you've done involving psilocybin for
depression the treatment of depression
um could we calibrate ourselves 25
milligrams of psilocybin is uh is that
what wouldn't it's going to be a
perceptible dose presumably
hallucinations and all that and is that
what one would find in um I'm guessing
here if I'm accurate this does not mean
that I have experience here but uh two
two grams of of mushrooms we think yeah
sorry I missed that uh I missed that one
went off on a tangent but uh yeah 25
milligrams of salicyline would be we
don't know and and it's important that I
say that because I wouldn't want people
to hear my answer here and then use it
to calibrate their own dosing of
mushrooms and get it way off so it's
guesswork and I would love to see
someone do a proper study on it and you
know
um look at the psalocybin content in a
given mass of philosophy mushrooms magic
mushrooms but to my knowledge that
hasn't really been done
um someone like Paul stammitz would uh
would give a better answer here but I
think the percentage within the mushroom
mass is some of solocybin in the
mushroom mass and thylacine which is the
metabolite of psalocybin is something in
in the one percent
a little bit higher maybe uh range okay
so one one gram one thousand milligrams
of magic mushroom would contain about 10
milligrams of psilocybin is that right
broadly speaking Yeah great that helps
calibrate
um and I think again just allows the
layperson to understand a bit more of
where we're headed with these uh
psilocybin trials and and the results so
we don't have to restrict our discussion
to just that one clinical trial but uh
if we include that one and and compare
to some of the other trials that you've
done I mean your laboratory is seeing
phenomenal in my opinion phenomenal
results in the treatment of otherwise
intractable depression major depression
so many people suffer from from two
um I suppose there are two sessions of
using psilocybin in these ranges of 10
to 25 milligrams do I have that correct
yes okay could we talk a little bit
about what people typically experience
during those sessions that allows this
phenomenal transformation of mood and
state and trait as well and I'm
especially interested in whether or not
it is the experience during those
sessions that is the trigger that's
necessary for the the transformation
from a depressed to a non-depressed
state because with the the impulse is to
think it is that what one thinks and
sees and hallucinates is
um and hears is so vital but of course
these drugs can create neuroplasticity
changes in our neural wiring presumably
for long periods of time so what are
your thoughts on the The Experience
itself and maybe for those who have not
done these compounds before you can
explain a little bit about what's
typical for people and what you think is
leading to that incredible positive and
pervasive change in mood State and trait
I would I would say that it's more than
impulse that is leading us to think that
the experience is important it's really
data and and converging evidence now so
independent teams independent studies
are converging on the magnitude of
certain kinds of experience rated yes
with subjective rating scales is
predicting therapeutic outcomes pretty
pretty strongly and very reliably
um and so that's guiding us now could
you say well maybe those experiences are
some kind of Epi phenomenon of say a
central brain action well absolutely but
then all experiences and Epi phenomenon
by that principle and yet we care about
it you know and it matters to us and in
our human relations with each other
so I think it does matter to a human
being when they're in a say a psilocybin
therapy session
and as the drug effects begin to come on
and their body starts to feel a little
strange and tingly
and uh there's um some initial anxiety
and then in their Mind's Eye they start
to notice patterns and maybe colors and
then maybe those patterns deepen and
they're Dynamic and they have this
fascinating organic quality are they um
patients in your studies typically using
a um an eye mask or so they're in the
eye mask so eyes closed yeah that's why
you said Mind's Eye as opposed to
looking out into that one of the major
differences to psychedelic therapy
versus taking a psychedelic because you
shut your eyes you know and it's a it's
a world away from taking a psychedelic
yeah a rave or something you know in a
sense good luck with that
um but in psychedelic therapy yeah it's
it's you know settled conditions uh
there's music playing and what I'm
describing here is very much the default
uh there's there's actually you know
very very little variability between the
different sites that have done this work
on these conditions
typically it's two people
ideally mental health professionals that
at least one who's a psychiatrist or a
clinical psychologist or some other kind
of psychotherapist or psychiatric nurse
um but ideally two who meet those
criteria with a individual who's
ingested the drug and music playing
throughout a kind of Runway into taking
the drug and then throughout so there's
continuity music with lyrics or without
lyrics to begin with and the music
typically is spacious to begin with
um
and then builds and becomes atmospheric
uh there might be I don't know some
tribal drums in the distance or or
something as as it develops or like the
sound of a bird in the distance you know
a bird's call
um and then as it gets into more
stronger drug effects uh the music
um starts to coax uh emotion and very
intentionally you know strings for
example would come in and uh
um it's it would be an interesting
experiment and one that we'd love to do
actually to see whether if you were to
pull that out whether the the
Psychedelic experience would be as
emotionally
intense as as it is in psychedelic
therapy when you have music there as a
default and across the board people
should find this remarkable because it
kind of is all of the published studies
that are now
you know having such an impact uh on
Psychiatry and Beyond have music there
as a staple component and we just take
it as assumption that it needs to be I
tend to share that assumption but it's
remarkable that it hasn't been tested
properly but it's that and you know if
you were to run with that and and if you
were a you know had a kind of Critical
Agenda you would say well this is music
therapy you know uh why are you making
all this fuss about psychedelics whether
it's music that's there in all of these
trials there's all these fantastic
findings so there is something to that
you know and you know this will team me
up probably to talk about psychedelic
therapy being a combination treatment we
have a hyphen between the two because I
um share the hypothesis uh the
assumption that should be tested better
that there is a positive interaction
between the two that there's a Synergy
between the two
um that's why it's psychedelic therapy
yeah hyphen just like car heart Harris
I'd like to take a quick break and
acknowledge one of our sponsors athletic
greens athletic greens now called ag1 is
a vitamin mineral probiotic drink that
covers all of your foundational
nutritional needs I've been taking
athletic green since 2012 so I'm
delighted that they're sponsoring the
podcast the reason I started taking
athletic greens and the reason I still
take athletic greens once are usually
twice a day is that it gets to be the
probiotics that I need for gut health
our gut is very important it's populated
by gut microbiota that communicate with
the brain the immune system and
basically all the biological systems of
our body to strongly impact our
immediate and long-term health
and those probiotics and athletic greens
are optimal and vital for microbiotic
health in addition athletic greens
contains a number of adaptogens vitamins
and minerals that make sure that all of
my foundational nutritional needs are
met and it tastes great if you'd like to
try athletic greens you can go to
athleticgreens.com huberman and they'll
give you five free travel packs that
make it really easy to mix up athletic
greens while you're on the road in the
car on the plane Etc and they'll give
you a year's supply of vitamin d3k2
again that's athleticgreens.com huberman
to get the five free travel packs and
the year supply of vitamin D3 K2 this is
extremely useful to hear because I think
most people think okay psychedelic
whether or not they have experience with
psychedelics or not get some visual
hallucinations some auditory
hallucinations some synesthesia some
visual auditory blending
um somata sensation you know rubbing a
surface and and being able to elicit The
Sounds in one's mind
of course
Etc but so seldom do we actually hear
about the the specifics of these
clinical trials in a way that for
instance points to music as one of the
perhaps key variables now
you mentioned that as people enter these
psychedelic states that there's a little
bit of initial anxiety
um
about a year and a half ago I had a
discussion with Dr Matthew Johnson who's
running some psilocybin trials at Johns
Hopkins as you know and he
um mentioned uh the critical importance
at least in his mind to this idea of the
patient quote unquote letting go or
allowing the experience to take them
someplace mentally as opposed to trying
to constrain their sensory and cognitive
experience I'm curious what your
Reflections are on that on that idea and
why
it might be so valuable clinically
um and this ties back to this earlier
this discussion we were having about the
unconscious or about psychedelics
revealing something that's there all the
time but that we don't have access to
um you know it's and again I'm I'm
struggling to find the right language
for this because we don't really have a
neural mechanism like you know top-down
inhibition or something like that to
explain how this you know unconscious
might be Uncorked in the Psychedelic
experience but to make it quite simple
and direct how important do you think it
really is
for the patient to feel like they are
quote unquote letting go and what in the
world is Letting Go in biological terms
yeah yeah well I think we'll get there
in terms of having the neural correlates
of uh the Mind revealing itself to
itself you know the uh emergence of
unconscious the unconscious into
Consciousness or unconscious material
into conscious awareness it's a it's a
wonderful challenge it's a huge
challenge but it's a challenge to
embrace
um and letting go very much is again a
staple component of how the different
teams do this work in terms of
encouraging a willingness to let go and
when we started out doing our depression
work and and did that first trial it was
the first trial of of a psychedelic in
uh formally diagnosed depression you
know where that was the target
population and depressed population it
was the first modern study to do that
and
um we visited Hopkins uh friends there
and and were
um mentored on how to do The Guiding
Bill Richards Mary cosimano they were
just so
um brilliant and and you know Wise in in
their
um in their guidance to us as to how to
do The Guiding in our trial and so this
phrase of trust let go be open you'll
hear a lot I don't know who fairly it
should be attributed to but I would
attribute it to Bill uh Bill Richards
meh yeah everything's borrowed you
probably got it from someone one else
but it's such a key principle and it's
almost like a mantra that you're trying
to instill in people Trust let go be
open and those different components
where the trust is about the therapeutic
Rapport that again you know this goes
beyond just intuition now we formally
measured therapeutic Rapport we do it
even with just a single item a visual
analog scale item the subjective rating
scale item
on the morning of dosing and we find
that it's a it's a significant predictor
of the quality of the experience that
you have under the drug in in the
Psychedelic therapy and then the
therapeutic outcomes X weeks or months
later
um so very powerful kind of chain of
sort of predictive components there that
trust essentially important and again
not just intuition but the data pointing
to that let go there's a Readiness a
Readiness to surrender to let go to not
resist and we do measure that too and
see that it's predictive of response
um and then the being open is about a
um a willingness to go there to confront
to be inquisitive
uh something that's easier said than
done can be terrifying you know when
you're dealing with a very vulnerable
population
it's probably more
the rule then the exception that they're
carrying some significant adversity life
adversity or Frank trauma that they've
suffered and so that message of be open
be willing to confront and to go there
is really you know it's really powerful
um and that that's how it plays out and
and often there is struggle there's
something going on that is I don't want
to be feeling this make it stop that can
be nightmarish at times but it's very
very strong and with these big doses
that we give
it's uh it's very strong and actually a
a student
um that I've worked with
um
I think now doing a PhD Arie Brower is
working on a fantastic project
characterizing the different phases of
the Psychedelic experience where the
early phase is dominated by
um negative emotions and negative of
negatively valenced feelings of anxiety
and struggle and then it's a different
story and the latter half could I ask
about that first of all I think that's
fascinating and important to analyze the
different phases and again I'm delighted
here because people typically hear about
a psychedelic Journey but we never
really hear about the the kind of
stereotypic components of the beginning
middle and end of that Journey we know
that there's a peak and that there's a
kind of a parachuting down and
Etc but
um when you say that typically there's
an anxiety maybe some negative valence
in the early stage do you mean about the
sensations people are experiencing or
about some prior event that's being
called to mind that they're remembering
um likewise for the positive phase of
the Psychedelic Journey or trip are
people do they still call it a trip yeah
all right for the uh I guess
we'll use trip for the psychedelic trip
are people feeling positive about the
experience like ah like there's been
some sort of breakthrough or they're in
a in a calmer state or is it that they
tend to be focusing on prior events that
were positive so in other words
is there a Threading through of some uh
concept that comes to mind for people
maybe about an earlier trauma or maybe
about a sense of self or a sense of
other forgiveness
um you know it could be any of these
things but what do we know about the
kind of finer details of all that I
would say the initial
um struggle is more against a general
drug effects than pinning it on on
something specific
it's more that you know normal waking
consciousness we have a sense generally
speaking if we're well or well enough a
sense of assuredness about what's what
you know there's a table here and and so
on and uh and and we have that
assuredness in to an extent about
ourselves as well it might be illusory
but we have it and what the drugs doing
is it's breaking down all of that and
it's scary as hell you know and if it's
a big dose it's just like human nature
to to re you know rage against that a
bit and a bit like dying you know I
don't want this it feels like I could be
dying
um I might lose my mind yeah that never
comes those two are the classics is oh
but I might you know I might know that
I've taken a psychedelic and I might
even know a bit about psychedelics but I
still fear that I'm gonna go mad
um or that I know they you know
generally speaking these drugs don't
have a high
um you know fertility
um
uh risk uh I still think I'm gonna die
you know um and it's just it's very
palpable in that and that comes up so
yeah that's that I mean those are the
core fears that uh those two and very
reliably that comes up and it's really
like a basic drug action it's dose
dependent but it's a basic drug action
that is forcing something about the
nature of the mind and the way it's made
up that makes it feel that way oh but it
feels like I'm losing my mind or it
feels like I could lose my mind or that
I could go insane or that maybe I'm I'm
dying here and this is bad yeah yeah
you've talked many times before and have
done really wonderful work looking at
the changes in communication between
different brain areas while under while
people are under the influence of
psychedelics and I think the Gestalt of
those data correct me if I'm wrong is
that um compared to the non-psychedelic
state that under psychedelic influence
there is far more let's just call it
interconnectivity or communication
um between eight brain areas that
typically aren't communicating which
probably is not surprising to people
given the the subjective effects of
these of these drugs
what is the evidence that after the
Psychedelic journey is over that some or
perhaps all of that enhanced
communication across brain areas is
maintained and if so what role do you
feel that could play in these incredible
positive therapeutic outcomes yeah
so we we've had a
some recent findings in in that
direction where yes it's true and uh you
know the uh picture that says a thousand
words some people might be familiar with
are these two circles
um a project that we did in
collaboration with some researchers
where ordinarily the communication is
going on
um within systems like other regions of
the visual system will be speaking
mostly within the visual system there'll
be a kind of clickishness or a
modularity to the quality of the
communication in the brain and then the
cool finding with solid Cy boom was the
first uh paper is that the communication
yes it sort of transcends these modules
and becomes much more intermodular
um
crossing different modalities and that
effect correlated with the magnitude of
the subjective effects and then we
replicated it with LSD using different
methods and new paper will come out soon
where DMT showing a similar effect it's
a bit of a debate about what regions are
most implicated but the general effect
of an increase in global functional
connectivity is what we call it or
Global Communication in the brain and
this is well under the influences so
putting people into a brain scanner
while they are under the influence of
the drug is that right yeah that itself
must be a quite an experience given that
these scanners are small tubes you're in
a bite bar you've got a bite bar in your
mouth that's a
um quite a quite a study you don't
always have a bypass or at least with
the psychedelics but yeah you've got to
keep your head still and uh and you have
the loud uh Emma scanner noise going but
because it's regular
um there aren't too many surprises so
it's actually surprisingly tolerable and
you're in a hospital setting so you're
not worried about what would happen if
you had a cardiac event professionals
around and you know most people
generally tolerate that setting quite
well surprisingly well but yeah we do
all that and and yes we do see that um
opening up of the communication across
systems in the brain and it does speak
to kind of intuition about the
subjective experience that
you know different modalities might be
blending with each other it is sorry for
interrupting but I have to ask is it
thought that the activation of the
serotonin 2A receptor is what's
responsible for the increased
communication between brain areas that
under normal circumstances would not be
communicated yes so there's a few
reasons why some modeling work the
computational modeling work that first
identifies where the 2A receptor is and
then looks at models its basic effect on
neural activity
um will recapitulate the the or
recreate the effect that we see actually
in the data with the scanning so doing
the computational modeling you can see
the same effect by knowing uh whether to
where the the key receptors are and then
making them do a certain thing that we
know psychedelics do I can imagine two
possibilities and I think it's important
to distinguish between these two one
possibility is that the activation of
this serotonin 2A receptor leads to
increased connectivity and thereby
auditorian visual hallucinations emerge
changed patterns of thinking emerge Etc
that's sort of the obvious
interpretation but
um the scientist in me has to ask
is it possible that
all of that increased connectivity is
occurring and yet that is a distinct
phenomenon layered on top of some other
effect of the Psychedelic drugs
impacting access to the to the
unconscious hallucinations in other
words is it the increased connectivity
that's leading to the subjective
experience or are those two things
happening in parallel well they happen
in parallel and they map to each other
but the question of causality what
causes what uh is the tricky thing where
I I would suggest that the the causality
is circular that they influence each
other and uh this gets a bit
philosophical but it kind of matters
because otherwise you know there's a
trap that it's easy to fall into uh
where you're thinking that it's all
about the brain action causing the
subject of experience and that's
typically what we do in cognitive
Neuroscience
um it's kind of like the sort of first
Port of Call kind of materialist
approach but one can be a materialist
essentially but still appreciate that
circular causality that mind also
interacts with brain
um and it's so hard to pick the two
apart and there is a kind of essential
dualism where subjective experience is
the thing in and of itself but that's
not to divorce it from what's going on
on the biological level the the reason I
ask is because
um as I understand it nowadays there's a
bit of a movement
within the scientific community that
studies psychedelics to develop drugs
that can essentially cure or alleviate
many of the symptoms of depression or
trauma that are built off our
understanding of how psychedelics like
psilocybin and here I'll throw MDMA in
there although classically not a
psychedelic it kind of gets lumped in
we'll get back to that later
but that do not produce
hallucinations or massive changes in
subjective experience actually I think
this is what initially got us into
conversation on Twitter as I had learned
about this paper published out of a
group at UC Davis that is essentially
modifying psychedelics so that they have
potential therapeutic application for
the treatment of depression but zero
hallucinogenic properties yeah and I
thought wow this is going to be a very
controversial thing in the world right
because the the history of psychedelics
as you pointed out has been one of
people accessing different modes of
thinking feeling seeing things these and
letting go trust Etc a therapeutic
relationship and here we have um I don't
want to say Pharma because it's not
really Pharma but we have Laboratories
who are trying to
um tease apart the activation of
receptors independent of all that
subjective experience in order to
essentially treat the same conditions
I'd love for you to comment on this
where you think it might be going
um and you know whether or not you think
that's the right or the wrong approach
if it has any validity at all
it is farmer it's just smaller Farmers
sort of startup farmer but okay so
because Pharma would like to have drugs
that can cure depression but don't make
people hallucinate is that or they would
and patience of mine and the system
would love it because the system is used
to it it's medicine right and it doesn't
give this this
um mental imagery of uh you know the
Summer of Love in San Francisco or of of
you know kaleidoscope eyes right uh it's
it's more uh yeah you could imagine the
um more to be careful with my wording
here
um those who would not be inclined
toward that would might might Embrace a
therapeutic that that is strictly
effective at treating depression with no
hallucinations yeah and it doesn't look
like uh you know an individual lying on
a cipher crying their eyes out uh
um about you know the life that they've
lived
um and that deep catharsis being life
transforming is very different from that
model
um I'm skeptical of it um I
for a few reasons um
and
one is that I I can't see the logic
um I can't see the pieces fit in a way
that's compelling
and I'm also skeptical because I think
it could easily be wishful thinking
because of that point that patients
would like it and the system would like
it and I just you can't you gotta bear
that in mind as well
um so wouldn't it be convenient you know
if it were true and you could get the
therapeutic action without the
Psychedelic effects well in a way that's
a little bit of what micro dosing seems
to be designed to do like you said take
dosages there below that that um
perceptual or some you know awareness of
some effect threshold over a longer
period of time in an attempt to Ping the
circuits or twist you know alter the
circuits but not hallucinate yeah not
have a catharsis so if
if micro dosing can do that and it's
sub-perceptible the micro dosing isn't
psychedelic action because where's the
Psychedelic action when psychedelic when
defined means psyche revealing you're
not getting that effect you might be
getting the pharmacology you might be
getting some direct serotonin to a
receptor agonism that could be driving a
therapeutic response but you can get
that with ssris as well you know and so
my point is what's what's new okay maybe
it's a bit new in people are now
developing direct to a agonists rather
than indirect through a serotonin
releaser like the selective serotonin
reuptake Inhibitors the ssris like
Lexapro you know are there any ssris
that selectively agonize
um which Folks by the way means activate
in a good way Agony sounds terrible
those are non-foreign might think that I
mean the disrupt but they can activate
this serotonin 2A receptor are there any
drugs that will do that that are not
psychedelic
I'm not aware of any but then again I'm
not on the second form of college there
are I mean are there any that are
licensed and used as medicines in
Psychiatry I actually had this debate
um recently on social media and I
couldn't see uh I couldn't see a
compelling example I saw two a agonists
that we use for other things you have a
compound like listeride used in in
treating Parkinson's but actually it's
more of a dopamine Agonist right so
they're always hitting other things
right yeah yeah I said tapping other
neurons or other things so is there a is
there a selective serotonin to a
receptor stimulator an Agonist
um that it isn't psychedelic that is
therapeutic in Psychiatry and the answer
firmly is no I haven't seen it yet will
they develop one well for patient's sake
I hope so because it would be great
um let's wait and see if they do I doubt
it will be psychedelic and I doubt it
would have much to do do with
psychedelic therapy
and it would be much more like the
system we're used to of chronic
pharmacotherapy take your drug every day
let's let's hope they find it and it
works for patient's sake
but as things stand right now I'm a
little skeptical
now some of the findings that are being
seen that are really exciting
fantastic work being done showing things
like increases in the communication
components of neurons dendritic growth
uh spine growth synaptic spine growth
yeah by the way folks just I'll
interrupt for the data necessarily Spina
the bone you know the not the cerebral
column but um spines are these little
like little tiny Twigs with bulbs on the
end of of neurons that are allow for
communication points between neurons so
neuroplasticy is often associated with
growth of dendrites and spines and so
forth which is what Robin's referring to
that reminds me and I just want to make
sure that we close the hatch on the
earlier answer because I interrupted you
is the increased connectivity between or
communication between brain areas that's
observed while people are under the
influence of the Psychedelic also
observed later after the effects of the
drug wear off yeah and then I'll just
throw in another question there because
we're on to this top topic now to what
extent do we think that neuroplasticity
structural changes in neurons functional
changes in neurons are responsible for
that and how long does that last let's
say I take let's say I come into your
clinic
um I'm a I mean subject in your
experiment I'd take do come in in the
morning I'd do my psychedelic Journey
five to six hours later um parachuting
back to reality
as we call it and then I go home
increase the connectivity lasts for how
long and how long are the structural
brain changes occurring well you're
asking fantastic questions and and
partly because we don't have the answer
yet but we do have some we do have some
data and so we have looked at first of
all the in a sense the functional
plasticity or what we assume it to be or
at least the functional changes the
increase in communication across systems
um that increase in global connectivity
functional connectivity do we see it
after the trip we know we see it during
the trip pretty well replicated
correlating with intense drug effects do
we see it after the trip well the answer
is we've seen it in two different
depression cohorts psalocybin therapy
for depression in one study where we
look the next day we saw it a kind of
residual
um
uh
effect similar to what you see acutely
being seen the next day and then in a
subsequent study we saw it also three
weeks later so we've seen it in two
independent data sets this decrease in
modularity is how we measure it it's the
same thing essentially broadly speaking
it's the same thing an increase in
global connectivity functional
connectivity and actually unpublished
we've seen it in healthy volunteers on a
correlational level not on an absolute
change level but if you look at its
relationship to a mental health outcome
and this is an important thing to stress
with the depression work we saw a
relationship between the magnitude of
that change the decrease in modularity
or increase in global connectivity and
the Improvement in symptom severity so
interesting yeah I mean what I and just
to State it different way so
um what Robin's referring to is when you
say modularity as neuroscientists we
think of the the different modular
networks of the brain that you know the
eye talks to a region of the thalamus
involved in Vision which talks to the
visual cortex which
you know eventually converges with
auditory information of course
um but there's a separation or
modularity of function this increased
connectivity is cross modular in during
the trip but afterwards as well and
you're saying that that correlates very
strongly with the strength of the
therapeutic outcome for depression I
mean the The Logical extension of that
is that extreme modularity of brain
function is um depressive in some way
now we don't want to go too far but what
does that mean that increasing crosstalk
between different modules of the brain
is so strongly correlated with a
positive therapeutic outcome we don't
know other than as a relationship I mean
this is this is the thing we need to be
a little careful not to run with it too
far I mean there's some things that it
suggests I think it suggests a more
flexible
uh mode of brain functioning if you're
not getting stuck in modules or the
modules aren't
um excessively cut off from each other
but you see different things with with
different presentations if you were to
look at cognition sharper cognition is
actually associated with more modularity
so it's a rule that's a little slippery
and we need to be careful with it I I
just uh again I'll forgive me for
entering but I think I have friends who
are um
I would say are on the Spectrum who are
um very linear in their thinking and
extremely intelligent in a in the kind
of classic sense of being able to
ratchet through hard problems to arrive
at a solution and then I have friends
who are let's just call them what they
are from the creative communities
outside of science that um are very
expansive
um they see connections between many
different things but you sometimes you
have to not all of them but you have to
catch their ideas with a butterfly net
and oftentimes what they're saying
doesn't sometimes it just doesn't make
any sense now they also produce
incredible creative works but to have a
conversation with them is anything but a
linear experience they are not random
thought generators
um but there's a non-linearity or
Randomness to their processing that's
distinct from these other folks that I'm
describing as on the Spectrum and of
course it's a spectrum there's a whole
range in between yeah um it sounds to me
like there is some therapeutic value to
being able to move along this continuum
from the more linear to the non-linear
is that is that well I think so yeah
it's resonating what you're saying it's
speaking to my intuition that you know
uh you could be very passy you know
passing things up chopping things up
like an analytical scientists
splitter as we say inside you're either
a lumper or a splitter yep well you know
the way I'm being very particular about
what what when to call something
psychedelic you know that that kind of
passy analytical way of thinking you
would you might associate with a more
modular system you know
um whereas the system that's more
globally interconnected and open yeah
might be more flexible and creative and
Divergent in the associations and so on
so yes that's speaking to my intuition
too how you're describing it and I
imagine if you take severe
Psychopathology severe mental illness
like a depression I've always thought
that there's something intuitive about
out the term itself like a depression in
a landscape you know which is a whole
physical depression a physical
depression that it's easy to fall into
and if you do it's hard to get out of so
almost
um if I understand what you're saying
correctly almost like getting
um stuck at one location on this
Continuum because most people don't
reside at one or extreme one extreme or
the other full-time and kind of migrate
back and forth between expansive States
and more linear States like like you do
with low mood you know if you're healthy
and inverted commas you can feel your
low mood your disappointment but you can
spring back but someone you know you can
spring back yeah right whereas the
suicidal depressive person or suicidally
depressed person
um
somehow at least in my understanding
there there's something about that
extreme depressive States and extreme
anxiety States something my laboratory
is a bit more familiar with anxiety
which Alters the perception of time such
that people feel like that negative
state is going to go on forever or that
if it goes away that it's going to
return at random yeah kind of a
vulnerability to the time domain yeah
yeah that's it and it's so tragic but
that that cognitive bias in depression
that everything's hopeless and and that
there is no light at the end of the
tunnel yeah so you know if you were to
get stuck in that rut and have that bias
then you're cut off from other things
other sensory uh modalities or modules
you know cuts off from the world cut off
from other people stuck in your inner
rut and uh so yes I think we're sharing
this intuition that a decrease in
modularity or an opening up of the the
system the brain
um could relate to an opening up of the
mind that is kind of enduring after the
after the Psychedelic uh dosing session
and yeah and and the third replication
was to see in healthies and Improvement
in well-being because they're healthy we
don't look at depression so these are
people that are healthy walking into the
trial yeah take psilocybin twice uh well
actually they do
um but the first dose is one milligram
which they they don't feel it's a
placebo diet micro yeah sticky Geo on
their heads
um to measure their brain waves uh
during each dose and one milligram you
see no change
um so we I think that you micro doses no
I'm just kidding against the microdoses
I've always just been a little bit
skeptical based on my conversations with
the scientists actually doing the work
with with um with uh
uh psychedelics it seems like the the
answer keeps coming back
do
to one or two maybe three
macro doses in a controlled safe setting
well that's compelling the evidence for
that is compelling and that's what's
making all the difference right now and
microdosing is just appealing but again
you know science isn't about what we
want to believe
uh it's about what's actually coming
through and what seems to hold up you
know to testing I'd like to just take a
brief break and thank one of our
sponsors which is element element is an
electrolyte drink that has everything
you need and nothing you don't that
means plenty of salt sodium magnesium
and potassium the so-called electrolytes
and no sugar now salt magnesium and
potassium are critical to the function
of all the cells in your body in
particular to the function of your nerve
cells also called neurons and we now
know that even slight reductions in
electrolyte concentrations or
dehydration of the body can lead to
deficits in cognitive and physical
performance element contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of 1
000 milligrams that's one gram of sodium
200 milligrams of potassium and 60
milligrams of magnesium I typically
drink element first thing in the morning
when I wake up in order to hydrate my
body and make sure I have enough
electrolytes and while I do any kind of
physical training and after physical
training as well especially if I've been
sweating a lot and certainly I drink
element in my water when I'm in the
sauna and after going in the sauna
because that causes quite a lot of
sweating if you'd like to try element
you can go to drink element that's
lmnt.com huberman to claim a free
element sample pack with your purchase
again that's drink element lmnt.com
huberman would you say that's right that
one or two or three sessions and how how
far apart are those typically spaced in
time
yeah typically one two three weeks
across the sites is the way people are
doing the the Psychedelic therapy dosing
sessions two sessions uh you know
Hopkins Imperial NYU
um that's been a kind of default to we
we actually used three in a current
anorexia trial psilocybin therapy for
anorexia two patients left to
see after 19 who've gone through the
trial very exciting results they're
using an alleviation of the the
obsessive thought about food willingness
to consume even healthier amounts of
food yeah even improved weight at the
long follow-up so so critical I went we
did an episode on eating disorders and I
learned that uh anorexia nerosa which by
the way folks the rates of are not
increasing it's been pretty stable
Through Time despite what's said about
social media and uh Etc but um anorexia
nerosa being the most deadly of all
psychiatric illnesses which is a big
statement because you know uh manic
depression so-called bipolar depression
has a 20 to 30 times the the typical
suicide rate uh basically many anorexic
or people with anorexia I think is how
it's now is what one says not anorexics
but people with anorexia off and die
many of them died yeah so tragic so
often young people as well and similarly
with suicide in terms of premature death
so the tragedy with Psychiatry is so
strong and and there so it's it's so
rewarding to be doing that trial and to
be seeing good results I have to check
myself a little bit that
um I'm I'm reporting on it in this
really promissory way and uh the trial
isn't yet publicly released and and
published so
um it's still ongoing as well but that
was three to three sessions it is three
sessions and I can't say what the dosage
is because we still have
um there is a blinding component
um but there are three dosing sessions
in there let's see now I think they're
two weeks apart
um and we do the follow-up
um yes I'd like to
close out this uh description of the of
the journey and the trip by extending
past the day when uh people actually
take the drug into this uh what I've
heard described as the integration phase
you know you have to reintegrate right I
mean all this La all this increased
connectivity during the session
hallucinations insights anxiety letting
go maybe Revelation maybe Epiphany okay
great at what point is that Consolidated
meaning
um are these patients or subjects and
studies having daily conversation with
their therapist are they journaling
every day and you know I want to keep in
mind that most people are not going to
be part of a clinical trial and of
course here we're not suggesting what
people do or not do but let's just put
it this way
um we're people to uh use psychedelics
what is the way that people can maximize
on the neuroplasticity and the Brain
changes in a positive way way in the
days and weeks afterwards in other words
how long does this so-called integration
last and you know what how far can we
take this I mean I could imagine that
um how often one chooses to think about
the insights could also have an impact
yeah right because clearly people went
to Raves clearly people did psychedelics
in the 60s we don't know if clearly
people do psychedelics now but we don't
have data on those people you have
access to the understanding of how
they're spending their time and the
therapeutic outcomes which we haven't
gotten to the numbers yet but again are
incredibly impressive you know in
upwards of as I understand it 60 percent
or more people getting relief from
depression yeah 70 yeah 70 incredible
especially when compared to the typical
uh
antidepressant treatments and and so on
so
what is this business of integration how
is it done properly yeah yeah gosh well
how long does it last as well
um a lifetime uh you know life is a
journey like a trip is a journey
um and there's always work to do you
know as Jack kornfield says after the
Ecstasy the laundry and yeah yeah yeah
there'll be other good ones as well I
forget them
um but uh yeah so the work's ongoing and
and and they're the yeah
um
but this gives you a foot up it enables
people to do the work more easily and
and that's true of the classic
psychedelics it's also true very true of
MDMA therapy uh for post-traumatic
stress disorder it's really giving you a
leg up making it easier to do very very
difficult work going back to a trauma
trying to digest it process it integrate
it
um so it's such an essential component
of the treatment model
um
but one has to be realistic as well so
you know by saying our integration lasts
a lifetime well people delivering a
service can't be there for a lifetime so
um what's the answer there
um and uh people are wrestling with that
issue right now
um and I I think one of the solutions
might be that it's in a sense on you uh
to a point you know the therapeutic team
can treat you to a point and then it
becomes what you might call practice in
a similar way that meditation is a
practice it's something that you have to
keep up and if it slips then things
could slip and and that's the way it is
um or you have a another psychedelic
treatment you know so people have even
used this term of practice in relation
to psychedelics where there's a
psychedelic practice like there's you
know a meditation practice
but I'm using meditation
um intentionally here because they
actually think that
um meditative practice
spiritual practice elements of spiritual
practice could be a very important
complement to psychedelic therapy uh
and I think it's probably doing
something similar in terms of promoting
an ability to sit with
uh a former colleague of mine said it
quite well in relation to psychedelic
therapy versus chronic pharmacotherapy
or like ssris being on them all the time
so psychedelic therapy allows you to sit
with rather than sit on and I thought
that's quite good
um yeah so you know the meditation the
mindfulness the ability to
yes be present centered but also present
centered and accepting so if things come
up
you can watch and process and then let
go
that Holy Grail of of mindfulness yeah
you know uh you know awareness without
reactivity respond you know I grew up in
the Bay Area and you'd hear this
language right and I'm not being
disparaging this I have friends that
are on the board of sln and work down
there you know and I've gone there and
it's you know and yet you hear these
terms right be responsive not reactive
which to a neuroscientist is like
grates on me which probably just means I
have issues but um and surely I do but
you know Elizabeth what does that mean
right it's sort of saying like oh to be
the Observer but not be drawn into the
experience you know and and again I
don't want to be overly reductionist but
what I find so compelling about the
emerging data because it really is data
on psychedelics as treatments for
depression and Trauma namely psilocybin
and MDMA is that it really seems to
allow people this space that that is so
commonly thrown around you know giving
space between stimulus and reaction I
mean Victor Frankel talked about this
but you know I've been reading a
wonderful book called The Prince of
medicine good dates back to the origins
of medicine very dense book people been
talking about this stuff and thinking
about this stuff for thousands of years
psychedelics seem to give people access
to that better version of self which is
remarkable what's also remarkable it's
perhaps worth pointing out is that five
years ago I never would have been
comfortable having this conversation I
would have been afraid to lose my job
Stanford magazine this week just
published an entire issue about
psychedelics with how ketamine Works
MDMA psilocybin with the appropriate
cautionary notes in there but clearly
times are changing
speaking of
which
I know you're doing a trial on
first-time use of psychedelics
what inspired that and what are you
observing and as you tell us that please
give us um a few of the the key Contours
uh what's the dose
um how old are these subjects
I'm assuming it's men and women are they
suffering from depression or not what
kind of what's the landscape of that
study and I I realize this is still
early days of the study or maybe it's
close to completion it's not yet
published however correct it's no it's
not published it's not submitted it is
completed so this was one another one of
our covid studies in a sense meaning
covert hit and we had to finish the
study and it was hard to finish the
study because of kovid that was true
about salicylum therapy versus
escitalopram uh Lexapro trial
um uh which is published New England
Journal of Medicine but the this was 20
that paper by the way folks will provide
a link to in the show note captions as
well as some of Robin's other uh papers
I think the 2022 New England Journal
papers really fabulous uh given it's the
different dosages and the comparison to
essentially what is micro dosing and the
comparison to Citalopram yeah that's
interesting that you you link the way we
gave small doses of psilocybin to
microdising we didn't think of it that
way we thought it was just a necessary
Placebo for the big big dose the 25
milligrams that uh yeah and so that we
could say to everyone we're giving you
psalocybin and not be lying yeah for
those who got estellopram Lexapro for
six weeks they they got a very very low
dose of soliciting but it allowed us to
standardize all the Psychotherapy and so
on but the the other study that you're
referring to uh was in healthies healthy
volunteers uh middle-aged uh average age
I think was 40 so not your typical
student study that is so often the case
in Psychology research you know all the
undergrads end up volunteering for your
study uh so this is um uh more more of
an age range and also I think it was an
equal proportion of male and female
all the staff actually were female which
the staff were very proud of and
although it produces its own potential
confound right to have all one one sex
of of of Staff possibly yeah they did a
good job in the sense that
um we saw significant improvements in
well-being at the end of the trial so
let me describe the design it was a
repeated measures design meaning people
come in you collect your Baseline data
and do a brain scan and you give people
um a placebo we gave people a placebo
and actually let me rewind a little bit
everyone's healthy volunteers middle age
never taken a psychedelic in their life
none of them
entirely you know fresh virgin people
coming in and uh and the plan is to give
them their first ever psychedelic
experience so that's what we did in the
study but to do it we have this repeated
measures design where they'll first get
a placebo
and we have the placebo so that we can
do all the procedures all the therapy
all the music listening but not give a
whopping dose of solocybin we again we
gave them a placebo dose of solicit in
one milligram we stick EG headsets on
during the experience to record the
brain activity
um from the scalp uh the oscillating
electrical activity and we do the MRI
scanning
um before and after to see deeper into
the brain and we can look at the
functional connectivity that we were
referring to earlier and also properties
of brain anatomy which we did in this
study so this the short story is that
all of the changes that we saw
both psychologically and
neurobiologically were seen with the 25
milligrams it all happened with that big
whopping dose and what did we see well
we did see significant improvements in
psychological well-being
we saw what I call the entropic brain
effect which is actually formally quite
accurate we see an increase in the
informational complexity of
ongoing brain activity recorded with EEG
on the dose of psilocybin
the activity becomes more complex it's
harder to predict across time it's more
informationally rich
and that effect correlates as it does
very reliably with the magnitude of the
subjective effects so the bigger the
trip the bigger the synthropic brain
effect
um now pretty well replicated finding
um but then the Mr the MRI and sink deep
into the brain was probably our most
exciting result where we didn't just see
some functional brain changes but we've
seen some anatomical brain changes as
well
and we use the technique called
diffusion tensor Imaging that looks at
the cabling of the brain the white
matter tracks
and we saw a change in major tracks so
we we sort of limited our search space
to really thick tracts
um really thick fibers and the fibers
that came through as changing were ones
that traveled between the prefrontal
cortex and and the thalamus and the
striatum
um there were two tracks two prefrontal
tracks that changed and they changed in
the direction of a decrease in axial
diffusivity
which
um could be interpreted as tracked
Integrity where a decrease would be an
increase in track Integrity it is
something that you see in the developing
brain the axial diffusivity decreases as
a brain goes from being a baby to being
a adult axial diffusivity goes down and
then in aging and pathologies of Aging
axial diffusivity goes up
so this is in the opposite direction of
of the results you talked about earlier
in terms of brain conductivity of a sort
of increased communication across areas
if I understand correctly and I'm
perfectly happy to be wrong by the way
that this decrease in axial
um diffusivity is translates to a higher
Fidelity of communication between the
prefrontal cortex and the thalamus and
striatum as opposed to less and your
description of this is somewhat like the
the
um transition from babyhood and
childhood to adulthood
um speaks to the same where we know that
there's a massive culling of connections
as opposed to growth of connections so
in other words as we get older we get
better at doing certain things and less
good at doing potentially most
everything else is that right
ish because the the change was
anatomical
um and not functional so the other stuff
was is really measuring
um Communication in in the brain by
looking at how the activity fluctuates
across time and whether those
fluctuations in activity are synchronous
between regions and if they are we say
they're functionally connected and we
infer that they're talking to each other
because they go up and down in synchrony
but when it comes to the anatomy we're
talking about the just static you know
material stuff and uh
um so we're seeing the fibers and a
property of the fibers change
um at least that's what we think and
recently we had an independent person
come in and reanalyze the data because
you know one of those things incredible
finding requires you know
credible
evidence really strong evidence and
and I would say the evidence at the
moment is one study so we need to be
cautious on that but we did re and
analyze it and use this um correction
procedure free water correction to be
more sure that it was a change in in the
actual microstructure rather than
something to do with the extracellular
space the the water surrounding the
fibers and it came through in fact the
the change was strengthened by doing
this correction step so these are are
this is neuroplasticity as the
consequence of one first time session
with 25 milligrams of psilocybin yeah
yeah so we're excited and and the two
different you know the second analyst
coming in uh wasn't sure she believed it
and then she you know thought this
correction technique might kind of kill
the result and then it came through and
she's like okay now I'm excited too so
we'll see we don't know what it means
what what does it mean functionally we
don't know how did the people change
well psychologically as I said uh while
being improved we did look at their
cognition and we used a cognitive
flexibility Paradigm that looks at
people's ability to notice a rule change
and then flexibly adapt their behavior
based on noticing this rule change and
people improved after the 25 milligrams
and didn't significantly improve after
the placebo dose
there weren't correlations with the the
DTI change that the cabling change and
these psychological outcomes but you
know with these studies in smaller
sample sizes you don't always see those
correlations come through
um so it's something we don't know what
it means but
it's it's a change in brain anatomy
that's in the opposite direction to what
you see in an aging brain or with
pathology of aging and it's what you see
in a healthy brain as it goes from you
know normal neurodevelopment into
adulthood
very very exciting and intriguing and I
appreciate that you highlighted that
it's just one study although from
everything you've said it sounds like
it's been done with immense rigor so we
will eagerly await the publication of
that study and us we can peruse all the
data and and the subsequent studies
I want to hear a bit about the study
that you have been carrying out on the
use of psilocybin for the treatment of
fibromyalgia I'm intrigued by
fibromyalgia because because I have a
good friend who also I won't reveal who
it is and no it's not me this isn't I
have a friend thing who also is a
scientist who's um sits at a fairly High
position in the National Institutes of
Health who um quietly has expressed to
me that they are incredibly frustrated
with the fact that the standard medical
community has
um largely ignored fibromyalgia and that
for many years it was kind of lumped
with things like chronic fatigue
syndrome and other
so-called again so-called I'm not saying
this but people often refer to these as
oh it's psychosomatic that's all in your
head which is a neuroscientist is a
ridiculous statement to hear because
it's all in your head your brain is in
your head after all your physiology and
your psychology are influencing each
other of course and and the the world is
starting starting to appreciate that
more but first of all maybe you could
tell people what fibromyalgia is what
inspired you to do a study on
fibromyalgia using psilocybin of all
things
um because that's surprising to me and
um if you are allowed to or if you have
access to the data and
um in mind share with us a little bit
about what you're discovering in that in
that study sure yeah happy too so again
it's solid Sub in therapy and the
population is Fibromyalgia syndrome so
this is people presenting with a
generalized chronic pain so unlike some
other pain disorders where the pain is
focused you can say it's my lower back
which is very common uh chronic lower
back pain this is more generalized and
it and for that reason it's hard
to sort of know what it is and that's
why it's been a controversial space in
medicine and it's been yeah it's had
that charged thrown at it that maybe
it's psychosomatic and just to your
point
um is anything ever you know
independent of of the Mind anyway but
this is actually a fascinating space for
how you know subjective experience the
lived experience and the mind can
influence the body
because there's some really interesting
literature around the
etiology like the how the pain has come
about in a sense like what caused the
pain what's the story there
and ahead of the trial I would say to my
colleagues let's just be careful because
there is some fascinating literature
around things like um a background of
trauma and um
how
um uh that can relate to issues related
to inflammation and how that can express
into things like
fibromyalgia syndrome I just said be
very careful though because if you go in
with an assumption that there's some
very trauma for example then there's
that whole other side of psychoanalysis
that massively tripped it up around
false memory and so on and so please
don't hold prior assumptions that you're
going to uncover
um very trauma in every case
now the team have treated I think eight
people
um
and it's going it is going very well
again I just want to be careful with how
I describe it to Matt you know to manage
expectations and not get too carried
away
but I check in with the team every week
and
um they're still based in London doing
the work
um and uh it's remarkable what I hear
about
the profound
experiences that people have under the
drug in this study we only give one dose
it's a very mechanistic study we
actually have the EG cap on in the
sessions like in the healthy volunteer
study but this time now taking into a
clinical population
and uh so they're in the I'm they're
they are wearing an eye mask
under the influence of 25 milligrams of
psilocybin most of them probably have
not done psilocybin before so it's a
little bit like the first time study in
some sense
they have
fibromyalgia that's debilitating in some
way they don't they want they don't want
it obviously and during the session are
they thinking about their pain are they
being told to think about their pain
they're not being told to think about
the pain in fact
um as I understand it while there is a
therapeutic model around acceptance of
the pain it isn't unlike some of the
PTSD work you aren't encouraging them to
focus on you know the index trauma and
then you know work through it and try
and digest it we don't do that with the
pain so the Pain's there
um but there isn't an invitation to
focus on it and that's probably one of
the differences with classic psychedelic
therapy versus MDMA therapy arguably
MDMA therapy is more like
a bit closer to traditional talk therapy
where there is more dialogue people are
able to talk on MDMA
um in the MDMA trials do you know
whether or not they used eye masks
um or because this seems to be an
important distinction between as you
describe the therapeutic trip versus the
trip that one does you know going into
the woods and taking so you know taking
sales I've been in the woods or at a
party or
um
while staring at a poster or or a leaf
um again I'm not trying to trivialize
those experiences I mean obviously they
can be profound but
um so I'm told
um but uh the MDMA trials
um seem to involve as you said more more
directed uh dialogue
um and sometimes even kind of empathic
connection between people but they're
actually looking at one another you know
the eyes and eye contact being such a
key part of uh the human uh social
cognitive connective networks
um so
do you know if they put eye masks on
people during the therapy pretty sure
that they have the eye masks there right
because a lot of the MDMA uh work and I
was part of an MDMA trial um uh it was
um as I understand geared toward
developing because it's an empathogen
empathy toward the self yeah so I'm
pretty sure they have the eye masks
there but they probably and it's a great
question because you could formally test
this they probably don't use them as
much the thing is with the classic
psychedelics if you're looking at your
guides or your facilitators and their
faces are melting or whatever you're on
MDMA you just might really start to feel
more connected yeah they might look
especially beautiful and you know sure
yeah and uh and yeah there's that uh
fascinating effect of loving you know
the people that you're with
um
and so yeah I imagine they talk more and
use the eye shades less and it is more
interpersonal rather than like
intra-personal or going inside they do
use a fascinating terminology that some
people have critiqued but it is a very
interesting uh phenomenon and it's this
notion of the inner healer they use that
that language a lot it's been critique
because it sounds very suggestive you
know and that's probably one of the
vehicles here driving the therapeutic
process is suggestion I think now to be
honest about that
um
uh but uh so when they go inside that's
another term that we use very much in
the classic psychedelic therapy work you
go inside you know you put the eye
shades on and people are encouraged to
go inside you know
um but when they do that in the MDMA
work especially they might be told
explicitly and listen to the inner
healer you know in that kind of language
so you could see how a cynic or a
skeptic could come in and see that as
some kind of like suggestive priming or
biasing
I think they they have a point uh
Skeptics often do but I I don't think it
it's all of the story and and just
briefly because it's an interesting
point
um speaking to that point a bit in our
psalocybin therapy versus telepran trial
we measured pre-trial expectancy and we
did it for both conditions
so you know what kind of improvement do
you expect with the Lexapro the
escitalopram at the end of the trial and
what kind of improvement if you go into
the solocybin arm and get a big two big
doses of salocybin what kind of
improvement do you think you'll see in
that in in that
um and um of course it was a coin flip
as to what um people went into and there
was no crossover
and what we found was that it was true
that we had a
um a sample bias so most people had
higher expectations on average there
were higher expectations for psalocybin
and its efficacy or Effectiveness versus
the SSRI the Lexapro
however when we looked at the
correlation
or the predictive relationship between
pre-trial expectancy and response we saw
that pre-trial expectancy for the
acetylopram predicted response to
acetylopram across virtually every
single measure all these different
measures of depression and anxiety and
well-being and and I think none of the
scales I'm pretty sure it was none of
about 12 or so mental health rating
scales was there a relationship between
pre-trial expectancy even though it was
high it didn't predict pre-trial
expectancy didn't predict response to
the salicyline therapy so that was a bit
of a you know smash on the head for the
idea that that
classic psychedelic therapy is some kind
of placebo response I think it's so
important to address that question
because
um
if it doesn't come through as it didn't
as it didn't come through then it it
opens up even more Intrigue about well
what is it then if it's not just a
placebo response or a super Placebo
response like an amplification of the
placebo response then it must be
something else and how intriguing it has
a direct therapy to action it must be
something and we don't yet know what it
is I talked about the the residual you
know increase in global connectivity
that's one possibility
but the truth is we're we're just
scratching the surface and yet the
therapeutic outcomes are again just so
marvelous marvelously impressive
um I'm curious as to why us well there
are that many Labs but the the
Laboratories that are focused on classic
psychedelics for the treatment of
depression and and now as you mentioned
promising results for anorexia and
fibromyalgia as well although
preliminary prom very promising uh why
the lack of attention toward uh LSD
um is it that the LSD trips are just too
long
is it that they are qualitatively
different
um are there any data on
um non-microduces of LSD and here I want
to be very careful because I learned
through my interactions on social media
that this term microdose is
um very misleading and in some cases can
be dangerously misleading because as you
mentioned earlier the effective
psychedelic dose or you know the
effective meaning that can induce a a
real trip with hallucinations Etc uh of
LSD is actually in the microgram range
so some people here microdose and they
think microgram of LSD is a micrograms
is a micro dose when in fact a macro
dose of LSD can be measured in
micrograms right so this is where um you
know in the absence of scientific
training people can really go go astray
or even in just a lack of understanding
of the metric system and since now
you're yeah you're a recent uh rival to
the US
fortunate for us sorry England's loss is
the is the US's gain by uh Robin's lab
moved from from England to the United
States recently so score one for us
um but why isn't there more use of LSD
in these trials
I think it probably is the duration of
the trip it used to be stigma
um and it was easier to get your
sonocybin study through because others
were they were getting that through so
there was the like Franz volvider in
Zurich and Switzerland and then Roland
Griffiths coming along and doing the
psalocybin work at Hopkins
so you could appeal to that precedence
and say Well they're doing it over there
you know can we not do it in in little
England
um so that's how it worked for us we did
actually go on and do an LSD study once
we'd kind of laid the foundations
um for doing this kind of work and it
was a brain Imaging study it was a
really extensive one actually where we
use both MRI and another modality called
Meg
um sort of super EG in a sense
um but uh you know why didn't we
um why didn't that turn our heads to
think oh should we not be doing our
trials with LSD
it's it does have something to do with
the pragmatics like a study day with
psilocybin is long enough to four to six
hour trip yeah and the FDA you asked us
to have the people in the lab and until
eight hours post dose which personally I
think could be quite excessive
especially if it's a low dose and you
know if you have that in the placebo
condition as well it becomes uh
impractical yeah scientists are not paid
nearly enough to Warrant the there's no
such thing as overtime in for The
Graduate students in postdocs yeah it's
often that there's you know more junior
members that are doing that really hard
work I I it was described very well to
me by a student when I was a graduate
student said to me they really can't
afford to pay us by the hour because we
used to work he was an
electrophysiologist so he would run
experiments no joke folks three to five
day experiments sleeping in bouts of two
hours here or there in a dark room with
a bunch of equipment and recording so
these are long long acute physio
physiological electrophysiological
recordings so um yeah no no scientist
does it for the money I promise you
um that there is money in Pharma there
is not money in uh personal income uh
it's not lucrative for the basic
scientist
um so yes LSD is what uh anywhere from 8
to 15 hours something yeah 15 would be a
little long you'd be a bit worried if
you were still tripping at that time
maybe with a really big time no just
kidding
but yeah eight hours plus and dose
dependent yeah if it's a bigger dose
it's a longer experience but you know if
you're gonna dose I'd say you know 10
a.m in the morning which is more or less
how it often goes then at 6 p.m still
feeling the effects
and then how long do you wait now to
kind of close things out before they can
go home even with solocybin you have
people still at work into the evening
and the staff are always there later of
course because they've got to pack up
and yeah so these are long days and it
and it it's just it it it's too much you
know that makes sense you know practical
constraints I learned from a a recent
guest on this podcast
um uh that we recorded with Dr Sachin
Panda who is a colleague of mine when I
was down at the Salk Institute is I've
pioneered a lot of the studies on
so-called intermittent fasting that the
reason the intermittent that the eating
period and these studies in animals and
now on humans is eight hours that's our
feeding window in these days is because
I'm the graduate student was going to
otherwise lose their relationship
because their significant other says
listen you can be in the lab for 12
hours that meant some hours before the
experiment then eight hours and then
some hours afterwards but you can't stay
in there longer and many people you use
the eight hour feeding window as a
consequence so the science has to exist
in and be carried out in real world
frame yeah no it does MDMA is a little
bit um
a little bit shorter right it's about a
four to it's also about four to six yeah
it's kind of similar to psilocybin yeah
it is and actually in the maps work they
redose after a certain point so the
Boost the Boost have a boost there are
optional booster yeah so
so there is that
um and now people are thinking well even
these psalocybin sessions are long and
expensive and if you have to have two
staff members there all the time that's
expensive that's where most of the
expense is is in the Staffing so can we
abridge The Experience make it shorter
and get away with it and get get similar
kind of therapies outcomes so there's a
lot of interest in that direction
they ask about um sorry to interrupt but
I want to make sure I don't forget to
ask about combination psilocybin MDMA
therapies the reason I ask about this is
um and here truly not me but I know
people who
um do self-administered uh
um combination psilocybin and MDMA
um I think I have this right I think
it's called a hippie flip
um there's another one that involves LSD
too again I'm not suggesting people do
these kind of drug combinations but
um the way it was described to me was
that the psilocybin because it's so
serotonergic sometimes can be not a
downer but can have a bit of a kind of a
kind of a murky feel to it some real
deep introspection sometimes in the the
darker Realms of one's psyche depressive
thoughts Etc not that it necessarily
stays that way throughout the trip but
that the MDMA because it has a very
strongly serotonergic but also
dopaminergic I mean so it has an
amphetamine component cocaine-like in
fact if you've ever seen someone on MDMA
their pupils are about the size of
quarters uh for a reason they're in in
you know um extremely extreme autonomic
arousal compared to a sedative
um which by the way would constrict the
pupils
um so they described the use of MDMA to
kind of balance out the kind of affect
component of it
um what are your thoughts on combination
psilocybin MDMA uh does this hold any
therapeutic potential this is obviously
a backyard chemistry
um in the sense that people are or you
know kind of cowboying the stuff on
their own which again I don't really
recommend I like to see the science go
first but I understand this is how it
works in the real world
um yeah what are your thoughts on
combining compounds yeah well I guess
the cowboying it in recreational context
but also underground therapists do work
with this combo that's what I'm
referring to sorry I'm not talking about
people partying with this stuff I'm
talking about there are
thousands now of therapists that offer
psychedelic therapies illegally really
because it's not legal at least not in
the U.S to possess or sell
um but that are doing this yeah so
that's really why I'm asking yeah yeah
and you know I think there's something
to be said for everyone has to be
careful with this as a scientist but you
know if they're doing it are they using
some kind of trial and error the same is
true of course with the you know longer
history of psychedelic plant medicine
Yusuf by plants we include the fungi as
well so in the extended sense plants you
know there will have been trial and
error there it might not be as
systematic as the science we do today
but maybe there's been a learning
process and maybe what they do
um they've come to because they found it
works so by that principle I'm
interested in that combination and
whether it does offer some advantages
maybe in certain patients you know if we
one of the buzz terms in medicine these
days is precision medicine
a Precision medicine and personalized
medicine so maybe there are certain
cases where you know introducing
um say psilocybin after the MDMA or the
other way around could offer some
advantages and the differences are
interesting you know
psilocybin can get you to deep places
maybe you know the kernel of your
suffering and and uh major life
experiences and complexes that are
causally linked to whatever the
pathology that you're presenting with
um but it can do it sometimes quite
aggressively you know and if it's a
post-traumatic stress disorder it can be
overwhelming and you can fight it and
really it's that it's that you know the
resistance is really challenged and they
fight back and the therapeutic
breakthrough and the progress isn't
happening because you've agitated the
defense mechanisms
whereas what MDMA offers is something
arguably more directionally reliable in
terms of in terms of the valence like
it's more directionally positive
generally an MDMA experience hard to
have a bad time on it yeah to be quite
blunt I mean but one of the concerns I I
had with MDMA I've never done it
Recreation I have had not and have not
ever done it recreationally but when it
was done in this therapeutic setting I
realized because there was music on at
the beginning I asked I actually asked
them to turn it off because I realized
that the um the music was becoming such
an attractor to my attention that I
suddenly was starting to think about
music and my love of Music which was not
the focus of the session that I had uh
saw was there you know for
um and I'm glad that they did turn the
music off because the moment they did I
was able to drop in within the I'm asked
to this sort of go Inward and address
some certain issues that at least to me
felt key and productive
um so that seems to be the kind of
Hazard with MDMA is that it's such an
empathogen that one could start to you
could go down any number of different
um rabbit holes yeah yeah but but it's
also it's a strength because you well
you know the classics like soliciting
can take you there very reliably but
maybe a bit aggressively
MDMA makes it easier to go there and and
that's its strength and that's why that
marriage of MDMA therapy for PTSD in
particular
is a is a good combo it works because
you are going to go there in a sense you
have to to Really make the therapeutic
progress you're gonna have to go back
there
um but we're we're going to set it up so
that you can go back there and feel uh
safer and more trusting and be able to
go back there whereas you've never
otherwise been able to go back there
without you know dissociating or having
you know horrible flashbacks and so on
so um that's the strength that it offers
I guess the limitation would be that
maybe it doesn't take you as deep as the
uh classic psychedelics and I tend to
think I'm biased on this one that
there's a kind of honesty to the
classics in that it is it is hell as
well as Heaven you know and that's the
psyche it isn't all roses and you know I
I really appreciate that you bring that
up because I think that there's such a
fear of uh uh so-called bad trips
there's such a fear uh in
non-psychedelic states to
um to avoid the the painful and
everything everything we know from
trauma and the treatment of trauma and
we've had several guests on here my
close colleague close close colleague at
Stanford Dr David Spiegel our associate
chair of psychiatrist clinical
hypnotists amazing amazing human being
and scientists and clinician as really
just you know like embedded this in my
mind that the only way to deal with
trauma is to get right up next to that
trauma to the point where some relief is
experienced there is no other real way
um and so I really appreciate that
you're saying that the classic
psychedelics may offer the the
um with a very strong nudge perhaps the
opportunity to get into the the
uncomfortable in a way that MDMA or some
non-classical psychedelics perhaps do
not
uh we were talking about time frames or
duration of trips and these different
compounds and how they differ and how
they're similar
um I'd love for you to educate me on DMT
and some of the work that you're doing
with DMT my understanding is that it's a
very brief trip uh minutes
um people I know who have done this
again therapeutically uh actually uh
I'll just point to one very exciting I
think
um group and initiative which is the
veteran Solutions initiative which is a
group uh this is carried out in Mexico
but in conjunction with Laboratories at
Stanford and elsewhere who are
evaluating the neural changes and this
involves ibogaine which is ibogo which
is a very long duration psychedelic 22
hours or more followed by a I think one
or two doses of DMT this is for veterans
with uh to deal with any number of
issues
um appears to be working with great
success and I've spoken to several
people who've gone through this and the
way that they described DMT almost
across the board was quote here I'm just
pulling quotes right anik data
um
the most profound experience of my
entire life even greater than the birth
of my children quote like being attached
to the shock wave of an atom bomb quote
there's no way I would do another dose
because the first one was so
unbelievable interesting by the way I
think most of us including me would
think why wouldn't you want to do it
again then but this idea that that was
just beyond anything so these are
significant excuse me these are
significant statements coming from
individuals who have existed at the
extremes of Human Experience to begin
with right these are so-called tier one
operators within Special Operations who
exit and may or may not have trauma but
DMT sounds like uh
big deal
yeah short duration really big deal what
do we know about its chemistry what do
we know about how it's impacting brain
networks and what in the world is going
on that people are describing it as uh
the ways I just mentioned a few moments
ago
yeah it's it's uh it's a rocket ship if
uh
if the salocybin is like a ship leaving
Port then yeah this is this is a rocket
ship into
craziness is that by the is it serotonin
2A it is yeah so it is a classic
psychedelic it's a direct Agonist a
direct stimulator of the serotonin 2A
receptor
it's a an order of magnitude less potent
than salocybin
but potency is a funny thing because
dose-dependent so that doesn't mean that
the experience with DMT is less than
that of psilocybin it's just that you
give more of the drug
um
uh but uh it has that's matched by its
its stickiness for the serotonin to a
receptor which is this kind of golden
rule in in psychedelic sciences that it
was discovered in the mid-1980s this
tight relationship between the Affinity
or the stickiness or The Binding
potential of a psychedelic for the 2A
receptor in particular serotonin 2A and
its potency and the stickier the drug
the more potent so LSD really sticky
very very potent you only need those
tiny microgram doses so DMT by its
Affinity is is
um a little less potent but by its
effects when you give a standard dose
it's just in in it's just wild and DMT
because there's another compound called
five methoxy DMT
which is a bit different
pharmacologically and subjectively it's
it similar in terms of its kinetics it's
another rocket ship
um both compounds
um in the wild so to speak are
um smoked often TMT and five Meo people
are vaping both actually now
um they're a vape vape pens that have
been uh
developed for people to administer
administer this but more traditionally
it's been a smoking thing this is
clinically not recreationally
or both both now I mean you know
underground practitioners are using the
vape pens they like them because people
titrate the dosage they get a feel for
what it is to be going into this state
so that they feel they can let go and go
into it
but um
and actually I think some of the
veterans work might be giving five Meo
after the ibogaine
um
phenomenologically if there's a
difference between DMT and 5meo people
might put it on
5meo being more of a reliable ego
dissolution experience less Visual and
more kind of
all-round immersion in the greater whole
loss of self-identity and just immersion
in everything yeah maybe we could just
talk about ego dissolution for a second
because it's such a sticky uh
interesting idea I can take a step back
as a neuroscientist and uh and say okay
ego dissolution this idea that the that
you know from a very early age we have a
concept of self
and that you know I wake up every
morning and I know I'm me and not
somebody else and presumably you do the
same and most most people do the same I
would hope but that and that there are
objects in the world and people in the
world Beyond us but every time I hear
about ego dissolution it sounds like
it's a kind of a temporary uh
elimination of the of the idea that
things stop and
um start and stop between us and
everything else almost like you know in
a kind of a here I'm not trying to sound
philosophical or metaphysical but
they're sort of the molecular continuity
of of life right we're all at all just
little little bits which is true which
is true right
um not a functional way to go through
the day right because you want to make a
cup of coffee you don't really want to
get lost in that if your goal is to make
a cup of coffee but um but you know
what is the the what is the
power of ego dissolution is it the idea
that we both that we like belong is it a
sense of meaning is it the sense that
we're we're not as important as we think
which of course could be a wonderfully
useful
um way to go through life you know to
think that we're not as in as in like we
are vitally important but we're not the
only thing right because I do believe
connection is vital as most people do
what is ego dissolution and why would
this
serotonin 2A activation caused that
that's remarkable yeah
great questions I mean what what is it
uh
you alluded to it with the start stop I
think you know because you could Define
it by boundaries in a sense what it what
isn't me
is as valid here as as the you know a
developing sense of what is me that a
child develops at whatever age
um
and uh
so a major characteristic of the ego
dissolution experience rather than just
a negative a thing going away my sense
of self going away is is the positive oh
now I feel interconnected with other
people and the World At Large and I
realize you know that there is that
molecular continuity and actually that's
a ground truth and oh maybe the ego
thing is somewhat illusory or at least
the construction of my mind and indeed
it is right well it is yes yeah I mean
there's no
transcendentalism about that it's just
like logic I think about about it a
little bit like family I mean we all
know what immediate family is but you
know sort of like um forgive me for
interrupting myself I do it all the time
anyway
um when I teach neuroanatomy you know
some clever student always figures out
okay well that's connected to that and
that's connected but ultimately
everything in the brain is connected to
everything else yeah there's just no way
around that that's a true statement yeah
and so you really just have to decide
where you draw the boundaries between
Where What Where are the modules what
are the modules you could say the brain
is just one big macro module yeah and
then you also want to include the body
and now fortunately people are starting
to embrace this idea that it's not mind
body it's both because the nervous
system extends through both of course so
as uh the same could be said of family
like we're related right not just by
virtue of the fact that we're human
beings if we did our genealogical charts
we would find a convergence at some
point
um and of course you know this becomes a
bit of a game but then one realizes that
where you draw the boundaries
and if you draw them at brother sister
parents biological parents Etc that's a
game too and so it is just a construct
yeah I mean it is a fun game you know
where do you draw the line and when to
pass and when to collapse it's also a
classic consideration in science when to
pass and the lumber versus the splitter
it's brilliant yeah but you ask this
question like well why do psychedelics
do it and uh
there we think psychedelics do it
because the target receptors at least
you know classic psychedelics do it and
that's important to stress so MDMA
doesn't really do it in the same way
might soften the ego a bit but yeah
that's debatable my experience with um
MDMA is that it's such a strong in
pathogen yeah
um and and that it can cause empathy for
others yeah certainly you could imagine
situations where one in the MDMA journey
and afterwards says you know oh these
these my oppressors you know or the
people that harmed me they uh and here
I'm not referring to my experience but
you know they did the best with what
they have actually have empathy for them
forgiveness but also for oneself that
there's an in a empathy for self I know
I said this earlier that is very hard
for most people to access perhaps it's
not the narcissists out there listening
they'll be like of course empathy for
yourself but everyone else I think
um uh all the other healthy people
um or the healthy people other than
narcissists and not picking on
narcissists I have to imagine they
suffer too in fact I think that's the
root of their narcissism
um that empathy for self is not
something that comes reflexively for
most people and here I'm not talking
about self-love or self-respect but this
notion of being able to see the self as
um not just deserving of love and care
but actually holding that in place while
in confrontation with something
challenging in a way that allows more
not less access to Adaptive responses to
that challenge I think that's the way I
kind of conceptualize it yeah yeah but I
mean drugs offer a great they offer
great they are great scientific tools
for tackling this question what is ego
dissolution and why do drugs modulate it
and what does that tell you about the
brain you know because other drugs like
cocaine releasing more of a different
neurotransmitter better dopamine more
than serotonin the opposite is the case
with MDMA is more of an ego inflator
right oh absolutely people become hyper
linear hyper um linked to their own
desires and wishes and future outcomes
become an obsession it's the stuff of a
kind of American Psycho and the uh kind
of cliches and stereotypes of the the
80s uh uh cocaine culture yeah yeah and
we did a study once actually looking at
dose-dependent relationship with ego
inflation on one axis an ego dissolution
on the other and saw that it just
massively passed or differentiated
between cocaine and the psychedelics
it's quite a neat study so cocaine makes
people's egos super inflated yeah and so
it doesn't touch dissolution and the
opposite is the case which uh with
psychedelics at least into your Imaging
to to explain how cocaine does that that
would be a great study yeah great
I have a sabbatical coming up I've got
12 months of sabbatical coming up yeah
yeah I'm gonna show up in your lab yeah
that's a really good one if it's right
to finish the thread on on why
psychedelics and ego dissolution we do
know some things or you know we have
some hypotheses and it's that the target
receptors the serotonin to a receptors
the classic psychedelics hit are heavily
expressed in what these days I like to
call recent brain because evolutionarily
its recent brain its cortex that humans
have more than any other species if you
look at a mapping of cortical expansion
from say macaque or chimp to human it's
the very same map that you'll find the
2A receptors in
um so that's the target it's and and
it's just easy to think that oh well
that could be the egoic brain you know
and uh and the classic psychedelics come
in they kind of they scramble up the
activity that's the entropic brain
action and in terms of you know the
start stop the boundaries
um that entropic action sort of spreads
out the system it doesn't shut it off it
sort of spreads it out you know
um the solution yeah and you know that
you were talking about the headspace as
well so that fits if it's you know if
it's more capacious
it sort of fits
um
the the big qualifier with psychedelic
therapy that that people rightly bring
up is it doesn't last you know that's
the Paradox of it the Paradox of ego
dissolution so the ego might go away
during the trip and you have these
profound insights about the molecular
continuity and how we're all born and
interconnected and then you come down
and however long later you know the ego
comes back but maybe with a Vengeance
and sadly you know things can go awry
when people haven't done the work
perhaps haven't done the integration
work and maybe ego defenses come back
and you know
and it's not it's not a pretty picture
uh how often do you see that in the
trials that you do
what percentage of the the of people
coming through what do you think end up
with
worse than they they were before the the
trial it's very rare in the trials that
we've done
um
yeah but you see defenses come back so
you you do see people relapse that's
more you know if you if you're pushing
out to like three months plus
in something like treatment resistant
depression that's more the rule than the
exception sadly people relapse if their
histories are you know histories of
chronic depression then while you might
give them a window of Wellness sadly it
doesn't last that's not to say that it
it doesn't ever last it does and we have
people who are in our first treatment
resistant depression trial who are well
to my knowledge today back at work doing
fantastically well
um but sadly the majority of relapse to
my knowledge and need to do more
psychedelic Journeys well they can't
because it's illegal that's been the
really difficult situation that we've
been up against is that we do a trial
where all of a sudden this schedule one
drug becomes a medicine in the trial or
at least an experimental medicine we
give the treatment it works
fantastically well gives people a
remission that they've never really had
for however long and and then the trial
lens and deny that treatment and worse
still if they were to have that
treatment they would be committing a
crime it's sort of a sick joke in a way
but that's that's the situation that
we've been in and that's a perfect segue
for what I want to talk about
um now which is what is the current
state of
legality in terms of or the progression
towards legality I'd also like to touch
on the role of let's just say incoming
big Pharma there are a lot of startup
companies now trying to capitalize on
these discoveries that you and others
have made
um you know the landscape out there is
very unclear to me
um maybe I'll just call out some silos
as I see them
and maybe we can draw some
um Bridges between them if they exist
at the ground level not the Grassroots
but at the ground level I Look to
Laboratories like yours Matthew
Johnson's rolling Griffiths some
Laboratories at Stanford uh Nolan
Williams
Laboratories doing studying the effects
of psychedelics in human beings so not
animal models in terms of their clinical
application
for the treatment of depression anorexia
I now know fibromyalgia trauma let's
lump MDMA in there as well I'm assuming
that it all works in an equivalent way
at the level of kind of where the
legislature is taking things okay so
Labs using government money philanthropy
Etc
then there are the um
the sort of the therapists out there
that are accessing what we believe are
clean sources of MDMA psilocybin LSD to
do this they are doing it illegally this
is in the U.S or uh other uh Western
European countries because obviously
it's going to differ by country
um who are administering these things
sort of on the basis of what they're
reading in these studies that you all
are publishing but also expanding on and
experimenting hippie flips and
combination drugs and ketamine and Etc
but let's leave ketamine out for right
now because it's legal but there's that
then there's the
um I don't want to say it's a
recreational slash open market black
market and here I want to raise a flag
to the fact that Dr Peter attia did a
terrific podcast on this recently in his
own podcast the drive the fact that uh
fentanyl lacing with fentanyl is now
showing up in MDMA and psychedelics that
are purchased on the street so serious
caution to those getting it from
uncertain sources
and and then you've got Pharma and then
as an umbrella for all of this you've
got the FDA and law enforcement agencies
which currently say this stuff is
illegal unless it's being used in a
clinical trial selling it or possessing
it can get you charged with a crime
ranging from I don't want to say because
I don't know but I'm up to felonies
right years in prison Okay so
can't take it through airports can't
don't get caught with it don't buy it
don't sell it kind of thing so where are
we going from that picture of these
silos
I know things are in clinical trials now
most people including myself are not
familiar with how the different phases
relate to the proximity to legality
could you just kind of give us the
landscape and touch on how long you
think it will be before
the people that come through your trials
could then go get a prescription for
psilocybin or potentially buy it without
the risk from a reliable source one
would hope but without the risk of
getting thrown in jail
um I used to live in Oakland California
my understanding and please correct me
if I'm wrong folks don't trust this
information and get in trouble my
understanding is that psilocybin is
decriminalized in Oakland but that's not
the same as being legal so what is going
on out there wow well so much yeah I
just asked 55 questions but
um but feel free to answer just a
subside of them if you like yeah well
Oakland's a funny one I I live close to
Oakland there are head shops in Oakland
um you know
um that might be selling cannabis and
and you know cannabis related
paraphernalia that are selling mushrooms
as well psilocybin mushrooms
yeah that's a fact I can I can verify I
haven't purchased them but I've gone in
and kind of checked it out like what's
going on here yeah yeah yeah so you know
uh the police aren't going to prioritize
um that activity the purchasing of of
those mushrooms as a crime now in
Oakland because of the decriminalization
so those head shops shouldn't strictly
be selling well they shouldn't be
selling
um they won't have a license to be
selling licenses don't exist yet for
that here
um but uh let's see whether they get
shut down they probably will I don't
know but there's a there's a church you
know in in Oakland at a sort of um
say that they're selling and it's part
of sort of religious rights that they're
using that church model as loophole
um
uh you know the way that Native
Americans can use peyote and they have a
more genuine
um a case I think because there is a
history there
um that they're trying to kind of
piggyback on that but anyway that's
that's sort of you know close to where
we are right now but um federally which
is really the major inflection point is
the FDA
um and the licensing of psychedelics as
medicines to be legally prescribed
across the country across the U.S and
Beyond
um that is close because the key
um phase so there are different phases
of clinical trials and the key one to
know about is phase three uh phase three
trials are licensing trials if they're
successful and typically have to do at
least two successful ones show the
results to The Regulators who are the
FDA the medicine regulators and say is
this good enough now for you to give me
a license so that I can sell and provide
this medicine that we've demonstrated as
a medicine
um so that work has been done with MDMA
therapy for post-traumatic stress
disorder maps have led that work and
done two face three trials I think
they've already publicly announced that
the second trial had results consistent
with the first we know the results of
the first because they're published and
they were remarkably good something like
67 remission rates and long term my
understanding is some of those remission
rates for trauma were years
which is different than what you're
describing for psilocybin where people
might need ongoing dosing that's true
yeah yeah but of course just for trauma
in those trials my understanding is
those MDMA trials were not focused on
depression yes yes focused on on the
trauma
um
so that's something because that data is
being filed now to my knowledge like as
we speak and
um they're anticipating a decision maybe
this year
um with rollout happening as early as
next year I mean that's sort of best
case I think could I ask you when you
say roll out who's real and it's the
appropriate term for MDMA so-called
rolling
um about 20 of my audience maybe 50 will
understand that uh not funny joke that I
made
um
who's going to roll it out is this where
would one get the MD that the clean
source of ndma meaning not laced with
fentanyl not laced with methamphetamine
um not undergone any chemical conversion
to some other drug which can happen with
extended shelf life Etc are people going
to go to their psychiatrist to get MDMA
and who's going to be providing it is it
going to be some big major Pharma uh
this seems like a serious set of issues
it is and I don't have all the answers I
do know that Maps would be providing
because they've done the work and they
have set themselves up in a sense
to potentially
become the provider whether as a Pharma
company which is the big question
they're wrestling with at the moment
it's very expensive to become a Pharma
company and yeah they probably deserve
to make the choice because they put in
so many years of hard work when all of
this stuff was considered like raver
culture party drug they were the ones
that spotted the therapeutic potential I
mean we knew there was therapeutic
potential based on work going back many
decades but
um points to them and I think that I
think in my opinion they should have the
agency to make those decisions yeah and
it's a remote such a remarkable thing
that's been achieved and I I think
they've done it all on philanthropic
donations
um I think so
um
yeah so
there there is this yeah big question
mark in the FDA are also asking
questions about
um to your question you know who who can
provide this because in the phase three
work and up until this point there's
been a Maps training a Maps therapist
trading and you have to do this formal
uh training
um in order to to be a practitioner
within the trials but now there's a
question from the FDA whether that Maps
training can be the training that a
clinician has to have to now be a
provider and when I say roll out it's
like
um
offering this as a service essentially
and so where would the referral come
from that's a good question that I'm not
100 on the answer whether it would have
to come from a psychiatrist or whether
someone's
um
sort of General physician could do that
referral but they will be going to a
provider who is licensed and certified
and will have done some training and
there will be a consensus on you know
what constitutes good enough training to
provide there will also be some
stipulations on the basic underlying
professionalism of the clinician who
provides so I imagine they'll have to be
a mental health professional I don't
think they would have to necessarily be
a psychiatrist they could be a I think a
clinical psychologist for all the
dosings I think without question there
would have to be a physician present or
at least within ready access in case of
an emergency yeah especially with MDMA
because of the propensity for cardiac
issues yeah because of the amphetamine
properties and where is um psilocybin in
terms of the phase trials is it in phase
two phase three it's in phase three uh
the solocybin therapy work being done
for treatment resistant depression by a
company called Compass those trials
which are always multi-site so there's
always a bunch of teams of labs in a
sense
um geographically spread out that are
each contributing to data that then gets
massed together and is then submitted as
part of the phase three trial results so
that's happening with compass right now
it's salar Southern therapy for
treatment resistant depression those
trials have just started and
um I think the earliest estimate that I
heard in a in a journalistic article was
because I don't think Compass would say
or they wouldn't say publicly something
like 2026 uh 26 wow so MDMA is is ahead
of oh yeah yeah it's quite a few years
ahead and it's more more of a not a
certainty but it's very very strong
position with MDMA whereas the work's
Only Just Begun with with soliciting in
terms of the phase three trials but then
you have this other situation of like
however many psychedelic research
centers there are now across the globe
um
it was nice to you know we had the first
one in London in 2019 first one in 2019
is 2023 now and I don't know how many
there are but so much has happened in
such a small space of time
um
yes but uh you know all these different
indications I've been able to tell you
about anorexia and fibromyalgia syndrome
trying to do a trial uh with a colleague
of mine at UCSF in methamphetamine use
disorder he's got a trial going on in
Parkinson's disease and chronic lower
back pain and bipolar disorder I mean
there's so much going on OCD almost the
full gamut of psychiatric disorders
um not schizophrenia to my knowledge
um are being looked at so there's so
much ground ground you know Groundswell
of activity
um and I think these small
investigator-led studies typically
they're small because trials are
expensive
um are going to be reporting positive
results so I know what we're seeing and
it'll be you know for let's see now at
least four trials or with really
positive results in very difficult to
treat disorders and that's just us and I
know there's so much elsewhere addiction
disorders as well you know Matt
Johnson's work obviously
um Michael Bogan shoots
so all this compelling Groundswell it's
really something and yet you know the
system to really make a big breakthrough
in terms of Licensing is of course slow
and it's that can frustrate people but
it it has to
it has to be done properly
um
else we we revert back to what happened
in the 70s where there was a lot of
interest
in psychedelics it's kind of interesting
to me there was a close juxtaposition of
meditation and kind of Behavioral
approaches to US self-directed state
change and psychedelics meditation kind
of made it through the hatch I mean
there were some years where it was
considered kind of counterculture woo
Magic Carpet weirdo stuff by Western
science
um but now I mean there are tens of
probably tens of thousands is not an
overstatement of quality studies
exploring how meditation can provide
advantages for the mind and even for
mental health
and psychedelics are now catching up but
they used to be close cousins in the in
the cultural framework
um but the problem was
I think psychedelics were viewed as
making people crazy and University
professors lost their jobs for having
discussions like the one that you and I
are having right now
um and some people went to jail but
mostly mostly people either left
academic institutions or lost their jobs
whereas now these are um some of the
these studies of the sort that you are
doing and that are taking place at
Stanford and Hopkins and elsewhere are
some of the greatest magnetic pull for
philanthropy for universities donors
are very interested in supporting these
sorts of studies because they and their
family members and people they know
suffer from Psychiatric illness for
which
um the current uh big Pharma approaches
simply have not worked so it's sort of
interesting to me that what once was
seen as
um kind of poison is now being viewed as
a potential therapeutic
uh it's not just interesting I think
it's it hopefully it speaks to the
evolution of of the human species people
seem to becoming more open-minded about
becoming more open-minded
that's a good one yeah
and yet uh
yeah it's uh there's so much that's
happening so fast and there's you know
there are elements of it's It's
complexifying the space there's uh there
is critique there's been some bad
practice in psychedelic therapy boundary
Crossing issues that have caused some
scandals that's too bad isn't it yeah
well you know I think to the gene
therapy right it just takes one bad
incident you know gene therapy was on a
fast track three decades ago and then uh
what sadly a child died in a gene
therapy trial and it's like shut down
gene therapy practically for half a
decade and then it slowly started
ratcheting up again gene therapy broadly
defined and now we're in the age of you
know potential directed gene therapy
using crispr and things of that sort
which makes people some people cringe
and other people very excited you know
if you have Huntington's in your family
crispr is like the most exciting
technology ever because you could
potentially eliminate it from your
family line going forward of course
so I I just really hope that we can be
balanced as this all plays out because
it it could go similar way given the
stigma given the history that people be
very Twitchy with with um some isolated
incidents
um and uh
you know over generalize them perhaps
um
in a sense shining a light on them I
think is important that that has
happened recently is important because
it really drills home how important it
is that this work be done right and and
what the necessary safeguards and
and standards should be
um uh yeah but it won't be it won't be
an easy Road forwards but um
but let's hope you know we've got to
hope that it succeeds because
current treatments you know people talk
about the Mental Health crisis and
to your point earlier about anorexia
rates it's not always actually the case
when you look at the
epidemiology when you look at the data
that you see a big inflection in you
know diagnoses or cases of psychiatric
illness I would say it's more that the
treatments haven't moved they haven't
really progressed they haven't got any
better since the 1950s more or less and
and new drugs have been more of the same
so there haven't been any Paradigm
shifts and that's why I get a little
impassioned when I talk about
psychedelic therapy and that point that
this is something different it's not you
know a drug every day it that system
it's not cutting it you know do we
really want to keep on with that system
uh sure you know not everyone will want
to trip and that will terrify some
people so much that they'll just want to
be on their Lexapro or or a
non-psychedelic psychedelic or whatever
and of course it should be allowed to
have those options of course and the
more options the better
um but I think there is
it's great value in really understanding
what psychedelic therapy is and and and
I think when you do you realize that it
is a major Paradigm Challenge on many
levels and and the fact that it's
different
might be it's its greatest appeal at the
moment I think
well I am certainly grateful for your
passion for the potential for
psychedelics to be added to the array of
potential treatments and I really also
appreciate how much you uh put it in
there alongside the other treatments
maybe even in combination with other
treatments as opposed to saying this is
the thing that's gonna cure everything
and yet the passion that you have for
this potential Paradigm Shift the one
that really appears to be happening at
the level of clinical data now
is so important
so I want to extend it a voice of
gratitude for that and for the work that
you're doing I mean I've been outside of
this field but as a neuroscientist I've
been paying careful attention to it
really for the last five seven years or
so and it's abundantly clear that it is
a small group of individuals who are
really thinking in terms of how the
system works now and what needs to be
done in order to change the system for
the better like yourself that are really
the driving force behind this new
movement or paradigm shift that without
question
is going to lead to improvements in
mental health and physical health
outcomes so I just want to say thank you
for that also thank you so much for
joining us today to share this immense
knowledge set about the history of
psychedelics what they are what they
aren't
um their clinical applications as seen
in your laboratory and other
Laboratories uh I'm sure people already
noticed this but you're incredibly
generous in terms of attribution and and
also in your caution about explaining
how some of the results in particular on
anorexia fibromyalgia are perhaps
preliminary but very exciting
uh they're not published yet anyway we
wouldn't call them preliminary uh and
also for touching on mechanism that it's
not just about people feel better but
pointed to some potential underlying
mechanisms in terms of connectivity
changes uh and on and on
so thank you so much for your time today
thank you for the work that you're doing
and thank you for the work that is sure
to continue we will provide links to
studies in your laboratory links to your
laboratory so people can learn more and
support in the ways that they deem
appropriate for them but just thank you
thank you thank you such important work
you're doing Robin thank you Andrew it's
been a pleasure
thank you for joining me today for my
discussion with Dr Robin Carhart Harris
I hope you found it to be as informative
about the science and clinical uses of
psychedelics as I did if you'd like to
learn more about Dr Carhart Harris's
research or support that research or
inquire into being a research subject in
one of his laboratory studies please see
the links in the show note captions in
addition please see the links to his
Twitter account and other social media
accounts also in the show note captions
also in the show note captions you'll
find a link to Dr Carhart Harris's
Twitter account where he regularly posts
about new advances in the field of
psychedelic science if you're learning
from and or enjoying this podcast please
subscribe to our YouTube channel that's
a terrific zero cost way to support us
in addition please subscribe to the
podcast on both Spotify and apple and on
both Spotify and apple you can also
leave us up to a five-star review please
also check out the sponsors mentioned at
the beginning and throughout today's
episode that's the best way to support
this podcast
if you have questions for me or comments
about the podcast or suggestions about
guests you'd like me to include on the
huberman Lab podcast please put those in
the comments section on YouTube I do
read all the comments not so much on
today's episode but on many previous
episodes of The huberman Lab podcast we
discuss supplements while supplements
aren't necessary for everybody many
people derive tremendous benefit from
them for things like improving sleep
hormone support as well as Focus the
huberman Lab podcast is proud to have
partnered with momentous supplements if
you'd like to see the supplements
discussed on the huberman Lab podcast
you can go to live momentous spelled ous
so it's livemomentis.com huberman if
you're not already follow me on social
media I am huberman lab on all platforms
so that's Facebook LinkedIn Twitter and
Instagram and on all those platforms I
post about science and science related
tools some of which overlaps with the
content of the huberman Lab podcast but
much of which is distinct from the
content on the huberman Lab podcast so
again it's huberman lab on all social
media platforms if you haven't already
subscribed to our neural network
newsletter the neural network newsletter
is a monthly newsletter in which we
distill down the essential points of
particular podcasts and we list Out tool
kits such as toolkits for sleep toolkits
for neuroplasticity toolkits for
optimizing dopamine and on and on all of
which is available at zero cost you
simply go to hubermanlab.com go to the
menu scroll down to newsletter and
Supply your email and we do not share
your email with anybody thank you once
again for joining me for today's
discussion with Dr Robin cart Harris and
last but certainly not least thank you
for your interest in science
thank you